Last chance for romance here.
Otherwise we're just going to film and then put it up.
Is it alive?
Really?
I sent her.
I sent her to make it happen.
We've been having problems with our tri caster.
It doesn't want to try.
It's like,
no today.
Every third show it don't,
just wired won't go live.
I centered the Cheeto I've,
I sent the energy dude.
You made it happen.
They did rare wake and bake day.
I know you don't know.
No,
I get shit done first.
Usually.
Can you not get shit done when you wake and bake?
I kind of fuck off things if I get,
if I get high at nine o'clock in the morning like Ah,
what's,
what's important really?
I get stuff done.
Yeah.
I have like,
you know,
I'll do like my cup of coffee and a joint and I'll get some stuff done.
I joke that it's like,
it makes me super motivated to do not a goddamn thing,
but I get stuff done.
I mean
all of this
stuff I get done as,
I like vacuum seven times.
I cleaned my apartment like four times the other day.
It's a math thing you share.
Someone's not slipping back into,
that's not put all the rumors out there now,
but you got any bread?
He Bravo used to say that,
but girls like he would if he was dating of glitzy.
Eddie used to work at a strip club and he dated a lot of the gals that a were
performers there and he said,
do you really know when a girl is a meth head?
Cause you go over a house,
it's always clean.
She's always cleaning that they can never clean enough.
Maybe I'm a method or just a Virgo.
Apparently.
Speed freaks.
Not method.
Sorry.
Speed freaks when people were on speed.
Maybe coffee is the thing that does that to me.
And then I just get focused from the weed.
There's not one ounce of dog hair in my house.
Really fresh.
That's crazy.
You have like $50 you're a crazy dog lady.
I do.
I have three dogs.
Wait,
don't you have like a pack of chicken in your backyard?
Dude,
I used to.
What happened to them?
Coyotes got them all.
I thought you were up with a bow and arrow.
We had an issue.
Where are a chicken coop burnt to the ground?
Oh fuck.
Fuck.
During those fires,
you lost your ladies.
No,
we didn't.
They,
they managed to fly out and they were in the yard.
We lost two of them because they wouldn't,
we couldn't round them up to get them into the chicken pen.
Cause we've got a new chicken pen.
What?
It wasn't as big and then they were too good for it.
I odis eight,
those two.
And then they realize that they're all on this one pen and one day when we're
gone,
they opened it up and got him killed.
All nine of them.
How they owe,
have they opened them up,
pulled it apart with her teeth.
You know,
dogs are,
listen,
he's a domestic one's domestic dogs,
but they're smart.
The difference changes.
Coyote and a domestic dog is like the difference between a hardened criminal on
death row and a baby.
No,
you're hundred percent right.
It's the experience and what you had to do to survive.
It's all they've done to survive.
They don't have a house that was feeding them food.
I mean they're fucking little wool and it's like literally doggy dog world out
there.
Yeah.
What was the
gentlemen,
Dan?
Um,
Coyote America.
The the author,
goddammit.
Was he like a doodle lived amongst the world's?
Yes.
Dan?
No,
he's a wildlife biologist and a historian and he was talking about the history
of coyotes and wolves in North America.
Apparently all wild dog species came from North America.
Even like jackals and shit like that.
Like they made it across over there somehow.
Like during the Pangea period or some Shit Pangea.
Do you know what that is?
It's the era.
No,
it's,
well when they think that all of the continents were connected together.
We are one,
we are one flat earthen flat table.
It was flat.
No,
no,
no.
Just obviously not a giant chunk and then the rest was water and then it spread
out,
which is fucking weird.
But what is happening?
How did that and like also is that happening on our insights on like it's
obviously on a cellular level of the things just splitting and being torn the
fuck apart.
Here it is.
Here's the,
the modern pangea map.
This is modern.
It's a modern country separations and all that because,
oh,
this is what it looked like.
I thought this is,
there's more.
It's still real America.
What is that?
I thought there was some knuckleheads and thought that is that really all of the
continents together?
Whoa.
Who is it shows you how much God damn water there is.
That's a mind fuck because you really like to think that we're all dirt and not
as much water.
It's so much water.
It's all water.
It's like a little speck in a huge ass ocean.
This was really crazy.
So it was ground dwelling.
Motherfuckers if figured out how sock all the fish out of that water
just to be able to get those suckers out your bare hands and then they were
like,
Yo,
we need something.
We need the smaller situation.
I think until they came up with the nets and stuff like that,
I don't think they were real effective.
I think they just got what they got and they ate that,
but the populations were fine,
but in the last whatever hundred and 50 years they've been using nets,
they just jacked that whole ocean.
What do you think happened to the dude who figured out like the hook?
He probably got all the pussy in town that do to like hook the fish.
He was getting all those fisheries.
He was getting the ones that were way deep to what?
The kind of pussy that you would get back when you invented a book.
You don't want it
in your mind and mind you don't,
but back then you're like,
Yo,
this is fresh,
fresh.
It only smells like must.
How'd you become African American?
Something's happening to you,
taking you to another level.
Another level for sure.
Yeah.
Let's guess how long ago do you think they invented the fish hawk?
Did they even know?
I'm going to say it's a really old invention world arrowhead time close to like
native native.
Those bitches would just break.
If you think about a big fish hooking like a little thin,
what would they make it a bone?
Probably must be hard,
but you would think don't want to be too heavy.
Show just sinking break.
Yeah.
I wouldn't be able to cook it.
Well yeah,
it must've been bone.
Yeah,
but bones get brittle,
especially after like,
you know they're off the body and they start to calcify and all that.
But how old do you think it is?
It's got to be really old.
Juniper,
what it says,
juniper wood was the first one 23,000 years ago.
Norwegians?
Yeah.
Those
are made from sea snail shells.
Well that's crazy.
A bunch of information I'll put together and this in Okinawa island data between
20 2003 80 and 20 2007 70 in that crazy that they get it that close.
They're basically in an inner give or take 80 90 years.
A hundred years there in that new room.
Like the,
is it carbon dating?
I mean that's the only thing I remember from high school.
How do you even,
how do you date it back?
Do they find,
is it like a forensic thing where they grab a fly and they're like,
yeah,
this was six years ago because of the juices on the wings.
I think it's,
there's like a bunch of factors.
One of them is the dirt that's around where they find it.
Like if they find it on the ground and it's covered with dirt over hundreds and
hundreds of years,
it could take some of that dirt and
they they're,
they're trying to test I think.
Whoa.
That's crazy.
Earrings.
Is that official?
Yeah,
I clicked the the shelves.
Those are fresh.
Those are really nice.
I would rock those.
What'd you comedy store?
Oldest fish hook found in Okinawa at,
wow.
23,000 years ago.
That's crazy.
So they're saying that the oldest fishhook is linked to the Norwegians?
I would say Japanese.
This is Okinawa.
Norwegian thing was saying that and up until the 1950s there were,
they were still using wood and
added fact want an ease.
Makes Sense.
If they all figured it out the same time,
different spots in the world.
It's one of those things like you don't like the,
there's just some weird thing who's that?
Is that Rupert Sheldrake is the morphic residence theory.
He's got this weird theory that I think the idea is that if some a rat learns
amaze on the east coast rats on the west coast,
we'll learn that maze quicker.
What,
how like uh,
like uh,
they don't know.
They don't know consciousness amongst the rats.
As weird as it sounds,
there might be some sort of strange connection that all rats share and not just
all rats but all living beings.
His argument was that if this is demonstrate a bubble with a rat in a maze,
that if they did something like a with human beings,
if they could figure out a way to uh,
to prove this,
that's likely what's happening.
Is it like he was,
he brought up a bunch of different factors like inventions that are
simultaneously taking place like all over the world.
Like you shouldn't attribute some of that to education,
right?
Like yeah,
definitely education.
What's going on like that,
the trends that are happening in education,
but they also think there might be something else going on underneath the
surface on a different realm.
Like
if you learn,
if we're all a species and you're on one side of the world,
you learn something.
The people on the other side of the world have like greater access to it in some
weird way.
That's really bizarre.
Yeah,
I don't,
that freaks me out.
That's like Matrix.
He's shit right there.
It's also unprovable and you bring it up to a real scientists.
They get upset with you.
But what's interesting though is the map,
the map thing,
the maze thing with mice and rats.
The cause,
I think that's safe.
That's been improving.
Uh,
pretty sure it has the thing that if you show a main or rat on one side of the
country,
they learn it quicker on the other side,
how the,
I don't understand how that can even be a thing.
But there's another one that's really interesting,
but I don't know how much of this is just cause they didn't observe it before,
but they've noticed that apes are starting to use tools
like cell phones to text each other.
No,
not tat yet.
Wa weren't monkeys using tools so islands together?
Oh
No.
Apparently they use tools like to get um,
like they'll stick sticks into a ant hills to get pants,
but they're also use rocks to break things open or money doing that before I
would imagine Abe's would follow suit.
I think they've done what they're saying is they're saying officially that
they've entered into the stone age.
Oh boy.
So like if we are watching,
if you saw a human evolve from being a person that you know what we,
whatever the fuck we used to look like when they first figured out fish hooks
granting to today,
you know,
there's many,
many generations of change and all,
all sorts of different shit that we learned that we are watching.
Literally the birth of that separation between like the regular chimps that are
just chilling in the forest to the chimps that are starting to figure out tools
and weapons.
Right?
It's the first day we see a chimp make a fucking spear like a spear,
sharpen it up and stab another chimp to death.
Planet of the apes chimps are becoming woke.
Is that what's happening?
I think there's becoming an enlightened and smarter.
I know,
think just chimps.
There was one with an orangutan.
It was amazing.
I'm marijuana town spear spearfishing.
Oh No,
dude,
you got to see it.
That's crazy.
I mean it's really crazy,
but like it's a beautiful photo.
It's going to be walking down the highway with like a briefcase soon.
I don't think it's going to be,
they're freaky man.
That freaks me out.
But it is a,
so we're witnessing evolution,
they're learning things.
And this one,
I think the issue was that this,
uh,
orangutan had watched fishermen do this so he had apparently watched some
fishermen like Stan on a ledge and stab fish.
So he decided to try to figure it out himself.
That makes sense.
I mean that's how all creatures essentially,
I mean puppies,
kittens,
they all learn is just to be,
it's to a limit.
They don't get past that sort of being able to use tools together.
That picture that's a wild is bringing up video too.
So I thought there might have been had video of it,
but um,
my dog opened his mouth.
It is dog food container when I was gone.
Damn.
A twist.
Yes.
I don't know how he did it.
I got to get a camera,
but I came home and that top was twisted off in his was like,
looks at you.
That picture
rang Tang spear phishing.
I mean that is crazy that you saw that in a movie.
You would say that is fake.
That is so that looks like a still from jungle book.
It's amazing.
It's an amazing photo.
That photo framed.
Jamie,
get a copy of that photo and let's do that.
That's a really cool room.
That fucker framed.
I talk about this picture all the time.
That is so wild.
So fascinating.
It really looks like the jungle book,
you know.
Um,
have you ever had your 23 and me done?
I,
you don't want them to learn about it,
but like how accurate is it?
You know what's with this science,
you're just going to trust a piece of paper that comes back.
I want him to go to the lab and see who's doing this.
Like,
how do you know you're not just getting some like,
you know,
general packet that they're sending back to you.
How do you know,
why would they do that?
Because they're got your money.
Why would anyone do anything?
Why are mother fuckers fro in fits in grocery stores?
People are crazy.
So,
you know when we're talking about if you get high,
you get a little bit,
just a little bit psychotic.
Like there's something,
something happens and you really do like enter into the world.
Schizophrenia.
Yeah.
Did it,
how do I know this science is good.
Done it.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I did it.
And what did it say?
All kinds of stuff.
Mostly stuff.
I knew that I'm mostly Italian and Irish,
but they,
they put Irish and English together,
which I thought was interesting.
I've 1.6% African,
um,
57% more neanderthal traits than the average person I could have told you that I
could have told without even the blood work.
I saw the,
I saw the paperwork and I'm like,
ah man,
I figures and then there's something wrong.
Look at that.
Look at that face.
Look at the head.
You're definitely Andra Athol.
You're like,
you're a link that's missing for sure.
No,
it's just a Italians in general.
And the don't be angry.
My Italian people,
because I'm,
I'm Sicilian was strange monkey folk.
Right?
That should be your next special title.
So when I was in Italy,
we had a cab drivers and the cab drivers would like to stick their head out the
window.
Stare at someone's ass,
we'll get to is a motto.
The slow down and speed up
their smooth,
but it's just,
it's just their savage.
They're like,
and then I thought about it,
I was like,
well of course they are.
Like they used to be the Romans.
Yeah.
And they used to be the anchor to everyone up.
I mean you're managing how gross life must've been like back then with people
gross.
It's gross now,
but it was really gross then without plumbing.
And I will say your toilet seats are the warmest I've ever sat on.
Thank you very much.
So it compared from here to the Roman era?
Yeah.
Nasty.
What did they do?
They,
they oil their oil.
Other shit though.
Went through the streets right of the problem.
That's why everybody was infected and sick.
And I mean there's no system.
They couldn't probably about Mulch,
you know,
maybe like fertilizer
to pour over it.
But that was it.
You know what?
I bet it was like,
it's like people throw their cigarette butts on the ground,
like someone will clean it.
Someone else,
a clean it,
some little,
uh,
you know,
some little hand will grab it,
some little poor kid.
But I mean there's no perspective.
They were just in their own little,
yeah,
they didn't know.
They didn't know they were living as sophisticated as anybody that ever did this
shit holes.
Is that where you shadow?
That's the shadow and you're around a bunch of other people.
Shadow
that looks like you putting your toes and you get Manny a pedicure.
That's what that little thing spread your toes apart.
Do you think that those folks had like curtains in between them when they shot?
Look at that.
Look at that corner seat.
Upper yeah,
right there.
How about that one is touching everybody's touching shit.
Yeah,
they were all,
they were all just in it.
Having a conversation.
Talking about the latest gladiator sports.
Can you believe the tiger got,
um,
I don't know why it sounds like that
when we were there,
they were talking about the front rows.
The front rows were all the rich people sat to watch the calcium and that was
when if a tiger did get out,
that's where they usually got to those people and killed a bunch of them.
That's ironic.
Ironic.
Just there to get a front row seat and then nature is like gut gow.
Gotcha.
Get sparked.
Look at these cars.
They're all jerking each other off.
She maybe sandals.
Oh course these everything in sandals.
Who's the guy with a Satchel?
All the way on the left.
Okay.
Covering his cock.
Oh,
okay.
I get it.
Oh I bet that's not true.
But dogs didn't shit in the whole year at oh this shit on the floor.
Shit.
On the everything.
So it was,
there were like,
what are these spoons for it?
There's other shifts with spoons too,
in case it gets cold.
Probably Scoop the water out.
Disgusting facts.
I'm gonna pull it up.
Oh boy.
Who's this guy?
Some guy would have video and discussing things with poop.
Yeah.
You guys have the nicest toilet here ever.
I can't imagine.
I mean,
what was sex like back then?
Even though they're in their own era and their perspective is limited because of
just where they're at.
It still must've been gross.
Disgusting.
They must have smelled terrible.
There's no soap.
No.
Well they must have had so it was like,
you know,
it just wasn't as fancy as our soaps.
Just no deodorant.
No deodorant was just oils and water.
What is going on here,
Jamie?
Or they're sharing that spoon thing.
I can't tell what the fuck is the school in a real moment wipe with or if the
pour water on it and Cosby.
Here's the other thing too.
Why not be a little further apart boys?
Yeah.
Why are they so close?
Hey fellow with the robe.
How about you scoot over.
There's a couple extra stall.
Share that spoon.
You don't want to be reaching
for that spoon on your butt to Bree was loose.
He was down a couple of seats,
but home needed a hand to hold.
I think what that was is they would take that spoon and they would wash their
hands and use their hand to wash their,
but that's so barbaric.
That's why I think you're not supposed to shake hands with your left hand in
some cultures.
I think take us there yet.
Yeah.
So you would uh,
take the water,
he'd pour it in your hand.
If I had to guess.
And you lather your butthole.
I mean why not grab a leaf?
Those fuckers are wearing leafs anyways.
His outfit and leaves
and the leaf outfit.
I think the leafs is something the added to those Roman statues.
When people got mad about the penis,
they got a little weird.
They got a little modest modest then without any plumbing.
Well I think they um,
they just decided that Dick's or bad.
I decided that a long time.
So they had a sponge on the end of a stick.
They would wipe them.
They shared a sponge.
Oh Man.
Duncan,
but sponge since we got these toilets that actually clean your butt with warm
water,
when you press a button,
nicest boats.
Also the cleanest,
like what are we doing?
Smear and shit around.
All you're doing is like smear and some of it off everywhere on the handles.
If shit came out of your nose,
would you be comfortable just smear in it like that and just give it a good wipe
in Rome?
Are we in right now?
No.
I'm a very clean person.
I wet nap,
that bung hole whenever I can all day long.
Keep it crisp.
Good,
boom.
Keep it crisp and clean.
Do you think that you would use one of those toilet things?
Hell No.
You wouldn't?
Absolutely not.
You'd see me crapping in the woods.
I mean this one,
the one we have.
Are you kidding me?
That's the most luxurious,
you know,
one of them have ever taken in my life.
There was like a remote control.
That's like the upper echelon of society crap right there.
It's a very fancy,
expensive,
no,
it's not.
I mean,
for what it does,
it's like very,
very valuable.
At first I was confused because there was a couple of [inaudible].
What's it called?
Brah.
I'm dawn.
Yeah,
give,
give them some love.
I think you gave it to us for free too.
There's a remote there too with a bunch of settings.
Bronto.
Yeah.
It's a very nice toilet and that's like a model from like many years ago.
They haven't nailed,
they hadn't nailed like,
oh no,
no,
these are recent.
These are the ones that we bought when we got the studio.
Right.
Yeah.
It wasn't too hot either.
Didn't feel like someone was just sitting there.
You know?
You ever have that experience where it's like,
oh,
that's weird.
There was a,
but just here.
Right.
This is a pleasure that you don't want
to feel good.
I'd rather uninviting him all the backs here as long since abandoned all the
crabs.
Do you,
do you like only crap in certain places or where you go?
Like cars on the road.
You travel a lot.
Like you just got to go when you got a gun.
Do you do what you gotta do?
Yeah.
I'm not scared in public?
No,
not even.
Just being Rogan and like being next to the person who's like,
what are you going to do?
I heard Joe Rogan shitting.
Have you seen the bathrooms like at Venice beach though?
Are you going in there?
Are these public toilets?
Oh,
speech.
see whenever you deal then that smell of homeless,
that why no peace Marone that is Rome.
This is a thing where he got pissed so close that people have been wearing
forever.
You know that super ripe,
pungent,
homeless,
crazy person,
smells
smell ever.
It's a weird smell.
Really similar,
but it's real similar.
Like this is what what when you hit,
it's usually a person that's got mental illness and they pissed themselves are
shit themselves and they get this really deep,
horrible odor to them.
Those who don't even know,
but it's so similar.
It's a similar,
it's like saying it's like the same smell,
like be oh like really bad.
Byo is almost always the same kind of smell.
I've been doing this concert.
Right,
exactly what to,
first of all,
that's the main reason why I've never been to a actually I would imagine.
Yeah,
we're just using salt rocks to clean our pitch.
And you found out that modern,
modern industrialized Yoda rand is really just a plot.
It's just a plot and you know what else?
Like furthermore,
to your point,
they really abuse it.
Chemicals and ingredients.
So this is like cruelty free.
Yeah,
free for,
nobody's like offended.
Well they make the product.
Yeah.
You either get it all naturale which is like rocks.
I've seen those things like mineral rocks,
rubbing your armpits
smell like a salty homeless person.
What is this salt in your pits work?
Is that what people do works?
If you don't have a deodorant or anything?
Lemon,
citrus,
you know,
anti bacterial natural.
No Shit.
That makes sense.
I'm a Reagan oil and that,
that's it.
Also antimicrobrial natural antiseptic,
Eucalyptus oil.
Some oil,
some men.
And you're another region.
So that might hurt my heart to coach.
Coach
a soap called defense soap.
It's all made with natural oils
is designed for grapplers cause grapplers get like skin scrap like scratches and
infections and a lot of ringworm and shit bro.
Oh a bunch of times.
I've had ringworm,
I've had staff twice and I had ringworm I think three times,
three times,
cause I've had it on my feet.
But it's basically the same thing.
You get your finger in poop and scratch,
right?
You are a doctor.
Clearly the fuck is wrong.
It's a poop bacteria.
I don't think so.
I think ringworm is just a parasite and it's what happens is it gets through,
I think it gets through broken skin,
scratch skin,
and then it forms this weird ring like a local bullseyes good fucking gross.
I can't,
I can't deal with it.
Like shows like the monsters inside of me.
I don't want to know.
Someone's sent me a link.
It was Josh Wolfe sent me a link about the,
the little like Mites that are in your eyelashes.
I don't want to fuck,
I can't even handle people in their cars and the four or five.
I don't want to know about fucking Mites in my eyelashes.
Mash.
If you could just see on the four or five as you're driving,
how many people have lice lights on the cars?
There should be.
That's the future.
That's what we need.
I don't want to know your followers.
I want to know how many licenses you have in your fucking life is a weird one
because license around when I was a kid and everyone got around,
first of all,
I can't get any more.
Thank you.
I know you're,
you're,
you're immune,
you're impervious to lice.
But when I was a kid,
um,
I was like,
what are they going to figure this thing out?
Because apparently adults don't get it.
Well,
I'll talk to hardly ever have,
it was the last time you had your hair check for lights hanging out,
napping in a kindergarten where the children are riddled with it.
But if I did,
how are the kids getting it?
Cause a role around going head to head,
talking about,
you know,
just gotta be patient zero.
What the fuck's going on with zero?
Some little kid would probably some rich kid whose parents neglect him and he's
had them in there for a long time.
Yeah,
he's got rich lice.
Rice.
That's funny man.
It really does.
It does.
It's kind of a,
it's an amazing,
it's amazing medicine for your brains.
Super Weird when you're not high and you want some people that are and,
and that what's happening right now?
No,
we're both,
all three of us.
Oh that's right.
Jamie's high too.
He's,
yeah,
he's very irresponsible.
Oven mitts on your shirt,
Jamie.
Oh,
that makes me want like a grilled cheese sandwich.
I don't know why.
Yeah,
but is that Johnny cupcakes?
Oh,
cool.
Wouldn't it be amazing?
Have grilled cheese sandwiches were super good for you.
Oh God.
It's my one thing that I just,
it's my food.
Like the one thing,
French fries,
French fries were the shit when they found out that it actually turns your age
back.
The trick does that work
part?
That's the worst.
If you just said the sweet potato fries,
bacon,
you're good.
It's not as bad.
I don't,
I think it depends on what kind of oil you cook it under,
but I think whenever you cook anything in hot oil,
there's something about the way the oil breaks down that your body's like,
what?
I think it gets carcinogenics doesn't it?
I don't know.
But I like when you use big words,
but can you pretend you're a doctor?
Doctors like a hey,
eat French fries.
Doctors.
Like I say,
it's carcinogenic.
Goddamn this health plan.
Fuck you Obama.
Fuck your [inaudible] pay care.
You can't afford healthcare.
Come over to my house.
I'll let you know if you're carcinogenic or not.
There's something real gross about people that are like,
oh well gee,
you know,
get better health care.
Go get better healthcare.
Yeah.
Like it's just readily available.
But that's one of the grossest ones when you don't,
you don't feel for fellow citizens and our community that don't have healthcare.
I know I've,
I've,
I didn't have healthcare forever.
Go Yo,
I got it a week ago and I booked all the appointments.
Did you everything.
I got the kitty cat checked,
got the teeth checked,
nice eyes.
Were you worried about the teeth you have or if you have the feeling like you
have a cavity,
like a phantom cavity,
like,
shit,
why is my tooth hurt?
Don't have a fucking cavities.
I definitely did.
My teeth were like crevasses.
Oh Bye Japanese.
Yeah.
She filled me like four times because I haven't been because health is
ridiculous.
No,
I wasn't eating candy.
You got all these holes in your face.
I don't know.
I think like,
you know,
changes in my life.
Maybe I got ringworm from you to change
to change as,
yeah.
Little kids get it all the time.
They do.
Oh,
due to the role in dark,
I'm going to blow you away and blow your mind away.
Okay.
Hookworm is super common in the south and it literally diminishes your capacity
for thinking.
So like the idea of drawed southern dumb person Theo.
No,
no,
I'm sorry.
I didn't know she was going to do that.
I would never have her on bro.
You know I love you.
I love you feel,
oh no,
not yet.
But maybe people feel knows relative yet to say that the field bog voice like
maybe a few people that I know.
Yes.
Yeah.
There were all hookworm uh,
victims.
What,
so how do you get hookworm walking around barefoot?
Ah,
I mean there's just too many opportunities to get these worms in your body.
Oh,
for sure.
That's so gross.
When you see dudes who go to like some foreign country and they get scratched
and they come back on a Bot,
flies gluten out of their head and their belly flying.
A kid just died recently in India.
I think it was India.
He got a infection.
He was having headaches and it turns out worms from pig feces had,
they had made it all the way up into his brain and they were making cysts all
throughout his brain.
When he died,
shortly thereafter,
they said it was so bad they couldn't even give him deworming medication because
of they did their award.
His brain would start bleeding and then it would suffer from a stroke.
I am not going to sleep tonight.
All is a warm talk that is a team here.
This the cirrhosis,
pulled those pictures out of,
find the pictures,
pictures of the dude's brain just like filled with sis.
Oh God.
Where are we looking at?
Cause we're to high and it's like 10 in the morning.
Oh,
you know what I was saying before I forgot to bring my fanny pack.
You.
You gave me one of your fanny packs and I travel with it everywhere.
Thank you very much.
I'm glad you enjoy it.
It's the most trying to spread the resourceful thing ever.
This is my fanny pack.
I can wear this for rental.
Same one in a couple of people have talked some shit and I was like,
you better step back,
step back,
step back.
I've got my pharmacy in there.
I've got my whole thing so I can be a doctor on the row.
Do you have a stethoscope?
I got a scalpel.
What's up?
He complained of having pain in his groin and swelling in his eye and then they
found out he had cysts all over his brain.
I mean,
I have pain in my groin every week,
but look at his brain on the,
on the right,
I'm assuming as a result
some it's different views of both.
Different use.
Those little holes are all cysts inside of bronc.
His brain is literally imploding.
Although those little spots,
those little white spots,
those are all little cysts inside his brain.
That must have been painful.
Fucking pure agony.
It must be pure.
And this was in India,
you said what country was this man was an India.
Yeah.
You know,
uh,
fuck that in.
Just imagine like people having,
not the access to healthcare in this country,
but at least we're a little bit modernized being in one of those countries and
being poor.
You're fucked.
Yeah,
you really are.
You're so fucked by swallowing microscopic eggs passed in the feces of a person
who has intestinal pork tape.
Bye.
Never going to brunch again,
but think about that.
It's not even just pork tapeworm it's the eggs in the shit of a person who has
the tape.
Did you see what God,
Jesus Christ,
Holy Hell is getting your mouth and shit.
I smoked a joint before this shit.
I am in a pure panic attack.
Don't eat ass in India unless that person is on anti tapeworm medication also
never eat ass again.
I mean this is a PSA for anti ass eating.
It is.
I told you I had he cool I a few weeks ago.
Yeah,
that was my life.
Will you saying,
Jamie,
the,
there's been a change in the way that the cork industry is going to be doing
inspections at.
The government's going to stop doing it apparently has of like early May and
the,
the industry is now taking over.
Oh,
that'll be,
that's a terrible idea there.
That's just exactly what you want.
This is one of those things where people that are all in favor of deregulating
everything.
You need to understand this shit like this happens.
If these people cut corners and we know people have cut corners before and maybe
it's not all of them,
maybe most of them are going to be great.
People are going to die.
You're going to get sick,
they're going to get equal.
Are they going to get all sorts of fucked up things 40% and replacing them with
employees,
cutting the number of federal inspectors by about 40% that is such a bad idea.
Well,
it looks like America and everywhere is going to get a whole bunch of hookworms.
This is like having the mafia police,
the streets.
This is like taking away,
there'll be no limits on slaughter line speeds.
Oh,
that is so gross.
No one is trying to make it quicker.
Pork is a weird one,
but pork is a weird one is too risky,
man.
It's way too risky.
Not even dad.
I mean they're,
they're fucking smart.
Yeah.
The of the weird things.
I don't like
smart like a dog.
They're like a five year old aren't they?
They're maybe not your kid like a five allow shots fired.
Wow.
Doctor fired right into my reproductive heart.
Your five year old would be like,
what do you think he'd be like?
Stoner.
Rude.
Ain't good.
Point B route c you're probably right.
I'm sure.
I'm sure you have a great five year old.
My Kid,
it'll be chill.
You know what?
He wouldn't be beaten up your kid.
But he made a very nice,
you'd be surprised.
My parents are hippies.
I know that's true.
I do know that.
Yeah.
My mom's a super hippie so I stepped up.
Um,
but port yet eating pig is weird cause they are very intelligent creature.
They're there until,
but here's the other weird part about it.
You got to kill him because they breed like crazy and in the wild they go nuts.
They're everywhere in the wild.
The tusks grow very fast.
They become those very barbaric,
those tusks.
Oh my.
See that little tray right here?
Yeah,
those pigs are,
they look like that's a wild boar.
Oh,
that's from my,
from Adam Green Tree.
He killed that in Australia.
They have a problem with them in Australia too.
It's wild how,
how hollow it is,
but it's so,
it's so strong.
Even still.
Yeah.
That's a big ass hook.
We should go fishing with this and see what we can catch up a well.
Yeah,
we could definitely cut catch like a humpback or something with this puppy.
It's a weird thing there.
Their teeth or they're shaped like these weird swords that is crazy and they
grow so fast.
If you were at least a pig,
they,
those things,
these things pop out in a couple months.
Yeah.
They start changing when they're not taking care of.
It's like,
it's like a movie with Howie Mandel walk like a man.
Do you remember that?
Where he was like a kind of vaguely,
he was raised by wolves or something that's kind of like almost the equivalent
of him coming back to society is releasing a pig in it becoming wild.
Not that I'm calling Howie Mendell pig,
but he's a nice,
he's just the opposite of a pig.
Very nice gentleman.
But he's also like a super clean,
he's not getting ringworm or hookworm there's,
and he's not getting any of the worms but he might because he like washed his
hands a lot.
Too much.
You can do too much and you kill your skin flora.
You fuck up your phone on flora,
you get the imbalance that's going on here.
What are you showing us?
Oh Man.
Wow.
He's like a dog man is a few.
It was like raised by creatures in the wild and this lady,
cause you know women,
especially a white ladies trying to like,
you know,
save him.
She wants to save them and do good for him.
And so he's just trying to acclimate to
great stoner movie by the way.
You're using.
This was [inaudible] 89 87
Dell's been around for him around and he looks younger now than he did then.
Dude,
you fucking dudes.
Maybe it's washing your hair.
Maybe it's a good move.
Washing your shaving it.
Oh,
washing your hands.
Yeah,
it probably is a good crazy.
Maybe we're very clean in this society.
We,
you know,
we can't handle like natural bacteria that exist in nature.
It fucks us up.
We're gonna,
we're gonna end up just murdering ourselves because of how clean we are or think
much more likely.
We're going to develop resistant strains of bacteria that are murderers.
We already have a new one that they did just did you see that thing?
Flu Virus.
That's like that article.
There's an article that just came out about a some mysterious infection that's
been Merkin people.
That's cause we're too clean.
We keep,
we should have,
we should bring back the Roman toilets just to level it all out a bit.
Have a couple of them sprinkled around.
Oh,
I don't think that's a good,
just a couple of them.
You know,
like they do one in a parks.
What's the difference between those in a Porta potty?
If you like working on a construction site?
I can't hold a hand in a Porta potty.
Do you ever go to like a music festival?
Fuck now and use one of them in the boonies?
Shit.
That blue liquid.
It's a low point.
I'm not doing that so I can get that warm that Theo's cousins have.
I'm not doing that shit.
Don't do it barefoot and he's showing me Jamie,
what festival are people at the art barefoot.
That's what Dina Horace.
The deadly fungal infection.
Resistant to treatment.
That's what it's called.
Or it sounds like a new solar system.
Unstoppable fungus.
Killing the world's banana supply man.
Addicted to sniffing his separately
man addicted to sniffing stuff.
Develop severe fungal infection.
That is not real.
It's can't be real.
This is like stoner news.
Here's another link.
Cut Socks aren't sexual says Kiwi schools fall down a click bait.
Click hold real quick.
Writing these like Gary Busey who's writing these.
How about what Tim Pool told me,
ready for this.
Do you know those clickbait sites we go to and it's like,
you won't believe what she looks like now,
and then you click on that and then you'd go to another one and she's like never
ending.
Click,
click,
click.
They get,
they gather up all these cliques,
like if they have a site that's responsible for like 400,000 unique clicks a
day,
if they have something like that,
they sell it to another company.
Those clicks and other company attaches those clicks to their site and it says
we get 100,000 views a day,
so they're not real.
They're just a bot or clicks.
You can buy clicks.
Dude,
what world are we in right now by and clicks?
I don't have time.
Please find out if that's true.
I think it is.
It sounds about,
sure.
I know,
I know what he's saying.
He doesn't lie.
He's a,
and I know a lot of people right now,
like,
Ooh,
people buying likes,
people who have done that or like followers.
It's the same.
Yeah,
the will.
They definitely do that.
There's a way to do that.
People get busted because like they don't have any interactions.
Like,
so they'll put up something and look,
I'll put up a video and the video gets like a thousand views,
but they have like a million followers.
There's no that,
that doesn't make any sense when the engagement doesn't match up with,
I watched people,
all kinds of dumb shit.
The amount of time that I've wasted watching people's Internet videos.
So a,
those little Instagram videos they make talking about their morning.
The thing you posted today about the Florida headline.
Oh man,
that was like the Florida headline for sure.
That was like what you said in the caption.
That was the jet.
I was,
um,
I'm writing this bit about exotic pets and uh,
when I'm in the middle of this bit,
I just decided to start researching.
What,
what inspired you to write?
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you,
I don't want to do the bit,
it was enough to says a Florida man tries to start naked bike club at chick fil
A.
Florida man was arrested after he challenged others to fight and to stare at his
genitals outside of Chick-Filet.
Birdwatcher.
Why did Dan Bilzerian say Florida just can't act right?
Trust me,
that's a good jam at himself.
Points points to Bilzerian or at least come and correct with that money.
That is a ridiculous headline.
Also,
where can I sign up?
It sounds fun.
It's like game of Thrones for Meth,
naked fight club.
You want to go to watch from a neighboring parking lot with binoculars.
That's you want to do.
You don't want to be,
you want to be far enough away.
So if they start running at you,
balls out your
keep your car in park engine running and then use those by knows,
you know,
I shut mine army
with your oven.
Mitt tee shirts.
Gotta be video of that,
right?
If someone was out at a Chick-Filet
depressing fact video video of almost any kind of interaction with
people,
create interactions so that they can videotape them.
Parents,
man,
they've got to stop putting their kids on video.
We've got to stop.
It's enough you say that,
but there's a little kid that's like six years old that reviews toys and he
makes $20 million a year,
$20 million a year.
Just looking at toys all open up a box of toys.
I'll do it.
100 beans.
That's it.
Nobody wants to see you open up to,
you're not a baby and I'm going to find something else to want to see little
cute kids in a diaper.
What?
How's this all going to hell?
Ah,
fuck.
I'm going to find another.
I've got to find another thing to make money.
Find another angle.
Yeah.
That kid.
He's making a lot of money going to be the youtube toy guy.
There's a lady who does it with just her hands of grown woman.
What does she do with her hands?
She opens things up.
Same thing for hands.
I don't know if they're beautiful.
I don't know if their feet out and start using the for fans.
What I to do,
I'm going to open children's toys and my feet.
Is that weird?
No,
you shouldn't do it.
You should do it and see which one gets better views.
Do it with you with painted toenails and doing you with kind of like neglected
Tony neglected toenail.
You know what I'm saying?
Like what little chips in your paint,
you know,
this is a neglected toenail.
Say that it's also kind of hot because it's the kind of chick.
They'll take some chances like
she's like,
she doesn't even have her toenails in order.
She'll abandoned wherever she lives.
She'll move with you across the country.
She's crawling.
She parking lots.
What's she do?
Enter into a bank robbing.
Skiing with you should be taking care of herself.
She's got chipped toenails.
No big deal.
That's a bitch who puts people first.
Just can't get it together.
Some people just never quite get it together.
Yeah,
and then you see their toes and it's a reflection of their own downfalls.
They're their own worst enemy or they have a job.
Busy too busy mom with a job and a couple of kids who's got time to do nails
then unless you,
you know you're a rich white,
you can do it myself.
That's the nail thing is interesting.
Why is that?
Because here's why.
Because it's like a service thing that people love,
right?
Love going and getting pedicures and manicures.
The people that are into that shit.
They love it.
They love Dunkin,
their feed and the thing,
and then they get to talk to each other.
But um,
they would never want to do that.
It's one of those weird things.
It's like if you found out your mom was given strange dudes pedicures,
look,
that's our new gig.
He'd be like,
oh Molly got,
go to therapist.
What's going on?
What?
We'd say,
why do you,
why do you have this job?
Do you really want to clean people's feet?
What?
What about it brings you joy?
Because if you need money,
like you might as well just slice mangos and the side of the highway or
something different.
But it isn't that weird that that's one where people love getting it done but to
do it,
but it'd be like Blah,
well I get my nails done regularly.
I love it.
It's very relaxing.
But yeah,
it's that weird thing where,
you know,
I was saying this,
it's like it's one of those jobs that's worked by non white people for the most
part,
which I think is interesting.
Don't you think that's interesting.
As a woman who's got her nails done,
entry level jobs for people that are first generation immigrant that like what
would happen realistically if all immigrants were moved from this country,
everyone's nails would look like shit and your clothes are terrible.
Then they got rid of all the illegals,
every,
everybody who barely speaks English out.
Restaurants would fall.
Oppressor,
delicious food.
There'd be no fun music.
There would be some fun music stuff.
Let's be honest.
But Chad does a lot of fun.
The most fun music.
There's a lot of fun.
Like it wasn't their idea.
That's true.
Out of fun Latino Music.
Not many like songs and like our culture.
Can you do one of these in it?
It fits,
you know?
Especially at like a wedding.
But yeah,
everyone will be jacked up.
Nope.
Good food.
No,
no nails.
Gypsy kings.
I don't know if I know Jim.
Very familiar.
Put It on fuck.
Are you kidding?
There's some,
it's too expensive.
No,
no it's not.
We'll give this yanked from youtube.
Oh,
that's right.
You can't put any music.
I put so content.
I think I just,
somebody sent me a song of Gypsy kings recently.
They've been around forever.
Yeah,
sounds familiar.
Latino band and what I love it is because I can't speak Spanish,
so when they're singing it's just beautiful,
like whatever they're saying,
it just sounds great.
It doesn't have any,
like,
I know there's a motion,
I can feel the guy's emotion when he's singing,
but I have no idea what he's saying so I don't,
I don't need to hear it.
I just love the sound of it.
Nice.
The language is like very melodic.
Oh yeah.
Like Spanish,
Italian heels take Latin based languages are very pretty.
To listen to those little Legos,
a musical flow,
like you ever hear people from Brazil speak Portuguese?
I mean I flick a bean to it all the time.
That shit's of men.
That's shit's sexy.
They have a way of talking.
There's an up and a down.
It's like a little dance.
Yeah,
it is a little dance and people where I'm from like Syracuse,
it's like go get a sandwich.
It's like you just don't want us to talk.
You don't know what it is.
It's actually to trying to keep people from breeding that it's like in the
places that sucked the most.
They have the shittiest accents because they're trying to make it everyone
disgusting.
Well,
I guess I'm not supposed to have a baby then telling it.
They're just chronic limit the numbers.
They don't want overpopulations in places that,
so there's probably some like legitimacy to what you're saying to them aside.
Turn your scientist.
Anybody who needs some advice,
just call us at one 800,
because there's a,
um,
a new documentary by the guy wrote coke,
cocaine cowboys did cocaine cowboys and a bunch of other documentaries.
Uh,
Billy core.
Yup.
Billy court.
Corbin.
You got it.
Oh,
don't,
why did I choke on his lane?
Some water.
Anyway,
Billy has a new documentary called screen a screw ball.
It's all about Alex Rodriguez and the steroid scandal.
And uh,
one of the guys in it is a fake doctor who would wear a stethoscope around his
neck.
Like he got his,
he got his degree in some Janky overseas university.
Wasn't legal to practice medicine in the United States,
but he would call himself a doctor.
And he had like the stethoscope that you'd wear it?
Well,
in his office he'd walk around with a stethoscope around his neck,
like hanging around his neck.
I just to get,
he's going to check your heart and he bought all these dunes prescribing
steroids.
It was amazing.
He's coming.
This kid that was walking around,
he posed as a doctor and had multiple patients.
Yeah,
I remember.
This is in Florida.
Same Plate I guess in Florida too.
You must be pretty easy.
Of course it's in Florida.
Does his name say Malika?
Yeah,
like a creepy name.
That's like children of the corn,
right?
That's like,
how do you pronounce that Malika?
Yeah,
that's,
that is ballsy dude.
Whoa.
Wait a minute.
That's not his real name.
Merit Malakai love Robinson maybe sounds like a character from like some sort of
porno.
There he is.
Dr Malakai,
a robberies,
he fat
d h h p Dash c a m p Dash TV
Dan or all those things,
HIV.
What are all those other things that he is?
Health care proxy,
maybe some bullshit amp.
I don't know what the hell that sounds like.
A gas station in Kansas
read his,
his thing.
Let's all it says is a wealthy doctor Malakai a love Robinson is a well rounded
professional that treats and cares for patients using a system of practice that
basis treatment on physiological functions and abnormal conditions on natural
laws governing the human body.
That doesn't even,
that's how run on or sentence you missed it.
Hold on a second.
Dr. Love Robinson utilizes physiological,
psychological,
and mechanical methods such as air,
water,
light,
heat,
earth,
photo therapy,
food and herbs,
therapy,
psychotherapy,
electro therapy,
physiotherapy,
mechano therapy,
natural path corrections and manipulation and natural methods or modalities
together with natural medicines,
natural process foods and herbs and nature's remedies.
Cool.
Oh,
what you just said?
The only thing that was true about that was manipulation.
Well,
how was this guy like?
Who,
who read that and went,
all right.
Yeah,
we're in.
Yeah.
Who read that was like,
I need to make an appointment.
Immediately found the real doctor.
All this other bullshit doctors that don't use manipulation.
What doctor goes like this and a photo.
All of them.
Now imagine that became the new thing.
I would not go to that doctor [inaudible] he had offices so someone had to like
rent him the spot so they believed him to not just the kidney offices or he at
least had an off a office,
like an office.
You kind of think a guy who's that good of a bullshitter that pretends to be a
doctor actually gets patients,
got a stethoscope,
got a website.
Is it that good?
Well,
it's good enough that he's got patients like it actually worked.
Like imagine being so crazy that you tell everybody you're a doctor,
you don't know shit about medical medical practices.
You know you read his little bio there and you get offices and then you get
patients.
Are you treating patients?
It's the same as like religion.
It's a similar,
it's a similar approach.
You just find people who are in need and who needs something and they're
gullible and they're vulnerable and they'll follow you anywhere.
Or religion is either that or it's a part of your culture.
Yeah,
right.
You're born into it.
Absolutely.
It's a cultural thing for sure.
It's when you hear a lot about a 45 year old dude becoming a Mormon,
they're like,
Huh?
You're like,
what?
What,
what happened?
What are you doing?
Your loss.
Maybe just have a great group of people that are all some Mormons you cite.
Fuck it,
I'll join.
I guess what would happen,
you know,
maybe even like with Scientologists what happens with people like,
especially in Hollywood,
they just get so desensitized or like they get everything they want and they're
looking for more.
I need purpose.
If I was jaded,
I would say that they think they're going to enhance their career.
You think so?
I used to think that
because there's a lot of,
like,
there was at least a lot of people in the film industry that were Scientologists
right.
And I've gone to a meeting,
no,
but I did go to one of those.
Um,
they,
they had like a conference tables,
a folding table set up in San Diego and they had like the,
the two,
uh,
coffee cans with the strings on them that you hold on to God and you know,
like they ask you questions about your childhood and weird stuff and then you
say it into the coffee can no,
you hold these things.
It's called,
it's called,
what's it called?
An eater.
Thanks so loud.
It's called an e meter.
You hold onto it and it,
um,
it,
it gives you some sort of a reading on this fucking graph that's,
it's totally nonscientific tore shit.
Right.
But you know,
the guy who was,
it was really interesting because the guy who was doing it,
it must be just like some regular dude who's in the church that they make do it.
It's not like he wants to do it.
Nobody wants you to do that.
You could tell he was like a volunteer cause he was like,
yeah,
maybe.
Maybe you have a problem with your dad or something.
Huh.
He wasn't really selling it at all.
So basically how I am as a doctor.
Right.
He was killing the Scientology.
Yeah.
As a side,
push it.
See what it's like.
Just out of curiosity,
just to be in there,
you know,
in that moment and see what the hype is about.
Well,
there's a lot of money,
right?
You have to think the date.
They're massive real estate holders.
They,
they've earned millions of millions dogs and they have tax free exempt status
because it's a religion.
Yeah.
Tax exempt taxes.
Oh,
it's crazy.
They sued and won it.
Yeah.
They sued the IRS.
See,
this is the problem where on one side of the coin,
like people are good manipulators.
On the other side,
people are idiotic to believe in deal with half of the shit that they believe
in,
deal with should.
I think they're there.
Bunch of different things at once.
You know,
there's the wacky beliefs that l Ron Hubbard,
all that stuff that he created,
but then there's also the clan,
like a mentality,
right.
For tribal mentality.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's funny that the Ku Klux Klan,
they kind of stole the word clan,
right?
Like the word cloud.
You say it,
you get self conscious,
you know it's the correct word for like a tribe of people.
Right.
And it's not,
it does not reserve for just oh,
group of white supremacists.
I mean it,
it definitely indicates a whole bunch of groups of people.
Look,
I,
I used to play quake competitively.
If you tell people how quick teams are that their clans,
the quick people like what?
And then they were like,
you mean like the KKK?
You're language?
No,
just a group of people like quake.
You fucking idiot with a common mentality.
That's it.
Oh,
a group.
A band of people.
A band.
Yeah.
Brothers
pins.
People just take over something and then that's something becomes negative from
then on.
Well then they have a platform as well,
you know,
they,
but they can then they're like social social justice warriors about it,
you know,
they're like cheering it from the rooftops and making tweets about it and how,
how it's a fucked up situation are they're really doing that.
Well,
you know,
when you,
if you
were to say any word,
people are like,
oh my God,
this person said this.
It's racist.
It's like I was just saying clan.
I wasn't saying anything else,
but it's like the Hitler mustache.
You just gotta let it go.
It's too tricky.
It is.
Anybody who wants to wear the Hitler mustache now,
like you can't really,
you can't.
Who wants to wear it?
Is there,
is somebody wearing it for a while?
That's right.
He did.
Daddy did playing basketball.
That's kind of fine.
Or if he was playing basketball,
he wasn't,
he was retired.
Hanes commercial or something.
I think.
Oh my God.
Damn Hitler.
You can't brazen.
You can't even like,
when does it become a Charlie Chaplin?
It starts as a Hitler.
Like when it gets to the outer edge of the nostrils.
Is it a Charlie Chaplin?
What Charlie Chaplin had a Hitler.
He,
he might,
he molded it after modeled after Hitler.
Yeah.
Hitler was a huge fan of Chaplin.
Absolutely.
There's,
there's some crossover there.
And chaplain was a huge fan of Hitler.
Hitler was a fan of Chaplin,
right?
In chaplain.
Just kind of,
you know,
cause Chapman was a little bit of a rebel man.
So why the chaplain?
Where's mustache?
A little tongue in cheek.
How Michael Jordan or mustache boosted sales at hand.
Let me see that photo.
Wow.
Larger.
That is so crazy.
That is wild.
Give it up.
Even Michael motherfucking Jordan.
What does that second paragraph say?
Jordan camouflage is the mustaches to a small extent with a corresponding soul
patch under his bottom lip.
But the lip beard appears to be exactly that.
A beard trying to disguise the two tonic neighbor upstairs sentence.
Yeah,
that's a great,
that's a great sentence to tonic neighbor to tonic neighbor that's really know
what to tonic means.
Do you know what to tonic means?
I've never used that word.
Capitalized it.
Hit it.
Maybe like a probably cause it's not a real word.
Motherfucker thinks it's a domain war or something like some.
Okay.
Let's see what says relating to towns relating to two tones,
denoting dramatic branch of the Indo European language.
Family definition.
You're like,
what's the tonic?
So go back to that.
Go back to that statement again.
That's the statement.
Oh,
they were just reading from,
yeah.
Okay.
Choose a beer.
Trying to disguise as to tonic neighbor upstairs.
How's that?
Maybe those people wore those stashes.
Maybe Hitler got it from those people because it's dramatic,
right?
Yeah.
But like,
who's the loading?
A dramatic,
maybe it was a dramatic mustache.
Yeah,
maybe it was all a mode of the times.
Yeah.
I mean maybe a bunch of people at Hitler's kind of like how there's full beards
now.
This is like as a full beard.
The Hitler of ours is just like a common beard.
Can you imagine if somebody wrote what rolled around with a Hitler mustache
today?
That'd be really wild.
You can't,
you can't,
that's too much.
Right?
But here's what's weird,
and I've talked about this on stage too.
Why is it okay to dress Gingiss con
who's dressing like gang is con.
If she want to do it for Halloween,
why is it okay?
Yeah.
What do you mean?
Like it shouldn't be okay.
Yeah.
Being a Nazi,
you can't be Hitler.
Yeah,
that's,
I mean,
that's just like won't let you,
well,
it's also kind of lacking creativity.
Like you want to be a Hitler.
It's like dressing up like a sexy baby.
Are we really doing this?
Is this necessary?
No one needs to see sexy babies.
No one needs to see a Hitler.
Well,
slow your roll.
Some girls should definitely dress like a sexy baby.
Girls can dress like sexy babies,
but I can't dress like a baby and open up packages on youtube.
You could just like a baby and open up packages on youtube.
No one's stopping.
You want to look funny?
Do and visible foes.
Cause you just said that it would be Q and now before.
It wasn't when I wanted to do it.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't think you're serious.
I wasn't.
No,
I wasn't so cut to this afterwards and it's just 10 videos of me opening up
packages of toys.
Yeah,
they'll just cereal.
Yeah.
In your underwear.
In my underwear.
Yeah.
Fucked up
with my terrible,
terrible chip toenails.
Yeah.
It's amazing how many people have created a career just reviewing stuff on,
on youtube,
like a,
those tech review guys,
they make a shitload of money and even have to have like degrees in electronics
or an engineering or anything.
They just have to have a love of tech.
Like our friend.
Uh,
well unbox therapy.
First of all,
Louis.
I think about how many views those videos get his videos.
He's one of the top ones,
but there's Marcus Brownley who's also been on here for you guys on there.
At least that are doing it.
Not Dunkin.
Yeah.
It's,
what are they getting right?
What does it like as a viewer to watch somebody else opened gifts.
It's like,
that's like the worst part of Christmas morning watching other people opened
gifts.
You're like,
where the hell are my toys?
People get really into it.
They do.
It's bizarre.
Flossy Carter is my favorite.
I've been,
there's a thing.
Yeah.
He's a Jack Black Guy.
He looks like a,
like a power lifter.
Yeah.
Tattoos on his hands full out.
Right.
And,
and he uses like a w w,
w he and he uses technical terms mixed in with like slang and he has a cat.
He's got a cool little cat.
It's always like in the videos nagging him and he opened,
he's an unboxing.
Yeah.
He's so super knowledgeable guy when he,
when he breeds like when he's talking about like the different details and what
the camera's doing dog.
But he does it in a funny way.
Like he's very funny.
Yeah.
In,
in it it's like also knowledgeable.
So if you're a dork like me and your intellect,
phone,
technology and I'm willing to phone technology,
I'm always fascinated by innovations and phone technology.
Cause it's like I'm watching someone build a bomb standard back,
right?
Where the fuck are they going next?
Where is this going next?
This has ruined us now they want to make them faster and better.
And Morton is he all hands to like she was saying?
Yeah,
he's all hands.
Yes,
yes.
Hands on.
So this is,
this is flossy Carter.
Shout out to philosophy as far as the lightweight,
super comfortable.
You can easily wear these all day.
And for the look,
this is what we're going to look like when you're wearing them.
Neck tattoos,
40 fucking silly,
but some people like them.
Some people don't.
These really ate my cup of tea.
Now what I am,
he's got big hands.
Big manly hand.
Well,
he's a,
there's pictures of him on his Instagram.
He's jacked like he,
he lifts weights.
He's huge.
What's his background?
I don't know.
10,753,495 views or his top 10 truly wireless earphones.
He's got a huge following,
but it's because of that because he knows what he's talking about,
but then on top of knowing when he talks about,
it's kind of fun to listen to.
Yeah.
His voice is interesting.
His voice.
The major.
Major Room.
Yeah.
That's voices.
Full.
Powerful voice.
You should do a Ted talk.
There's so many of the boys
fellows out there that are carving their own niche and gals reviewing things,
talking about things like there's so many different people doing shit like that
now.
I guess it makes sense because there's such a huge space for the techie nerds to
indulge in that stuff and become fans of that sort of,
well also no one would have ever made that a television show.
And if it was a television show,
people might not have watched it.
Yeah.
It's one of the air on,
on Youtube where you can just click it.
Yeah.
At your,
at your leisure.
That's the beautiful thing about the on demand.
It was tech TV though,
which is show on,
so it's the sort of just replaced whatever.
Yeah.
But Tech TV was never this in depth.
They would go,
you know,
they would gloss over things.
So they would have like a synopsis of,
it was still TV.
They still had,
you know,
they started,
did I commercials?
I guess they were,
they did everything right.
Like a television show.
It was great.
I would love remote control.
I mean,
not remote control.
What was it called?
I'm tech screensavers.
Remote control was the MTV show.
I was just looking at it.
I thought that was old Jenny Mccarthy and Chris Hardware.
Hard way.
Chris Hardwick wasn't,
yeah,
he had a couple extra lps on them.
Yeah.
You need a soul patch then as well?
Yeah,
he had it like a downstairs Hitler.
Hitler in the basement is what?
They're allowed to have a Hitler in the basement.
In the basement.
Just not in the attic.
It's too close.
But isn't it weird though that,
I mean,
not saying that anybody wants to dress like a Nazi?
I don't,
I don't want to just have to say that.
I have to say that.
Uh,
but that if you dressed like a murderer from the past,
like Gingiss con or something like that,
well you actually get in trouble now for cultural
appropriation.
You know,
where you wouldn't get in trouble.
Is it the renaissance fair when they have like heroes and villains day goes on?
What you're doing right there,
you got some squinty eyes
too far,
right.
And then we're taking it too far.
Well,
why is it weird that a physical characteristic like eyes,
like small eyes is like offensive to discuss is that
it is fascinating,
but I had to recreate,
I think.
Is it offensive or is it people enjoy the feeling of being offended?
I think there's a,
there's a sweet spot in the middle of there.
I would beg to differ that some of the people in society who are offended by
words,
term sentences aren't necessarily truly offended as much as they want to say
they're offended.
I am 100% on board with you.
So
doctor Peluso.
Sorry.
All right,
thank you doctor Peluso.
I have a HPB HD Phi Abd.
I can't,
I mean,
people get up,
they love it.
They love getting offended.
And you know what?
They also love doing?
Not doing shit about it,
but in their defense,
if you see like a movie where a dude is playing an Asian man,
but he's a white dude and they do some malarkey with his eyes like mother
fucker.
He said,
what did he turn him into?
A leprechaun,
something Irish some way.
Charlie Chan,
the fucking murder,
that special effects Malarkey and changed and went to a Chinaman.
Oh,
I that Goddamn Leprechaun.
That fucker.
You could be an Englishman.
No one has a problem with calling someone in English when we call someone a
Chinaman and no,
whoa,
you're getting weird there.
Yes.
It's exhausting when people are offended and then it's like girls being offended
and writing articles about guys that are doing me too moments,
but they're not going to the vet,
the rallies,
they're not involved in the community.
They're not really like moving the needle there,
just screaming.
Is it good to go to rallies?
I think it's good to be also actively and physically involved in whatever
movement you believe in.
I think just saying it and posting it on Twitter is a facade,
but it's good for likes.
You can get a lot of likes.
Boom.
I mean I guess there's some eyeballs on it.
You're,
you're creating a conversation,
but I don't know.
I just believe in like living,
walking the talk
a little bit more.
What the fuck were we just talking about?
The gangs calm.
Oh,
Chinese actors that get fucked out of roles by white people.
They don't do that anymore,
but they used to.
Yeah.
One of the big ones was Charlie Chan.
Charlie Chan was like a famous detective show.
Remember that show?
Was it?
But was it cast it as a white man?
It was a white dude playing a Chinese detective that was like super wise
detective that's busted.
But he looks like,
you know like a white guy eats good like Matlock.
More like a commish.
No,
like that's,
that's my holy hell.
Yeah,
that was Charlie Chan.
I'm offended.
Yeah,
he should be.
He looks more like he looks like a shitty magician.
It looks like chewy from the comedy store.
You don't,
you guys don't remember chewy.
That is offensive at the same thing happened with,
um,
let me see that picture.
Look at that.
The Shit is ridiculous.
He was happening there.
These,
it looks like he runs a casino in upstate New York.
You ever hear him talk?
Can we play some of the need to hear it from Charles town?
It was very offensive.
Oh my God.
Let's listen to some Charlie's yet.
I'm,
I'm right now.
Jimmy,
what do you think?
What year do you think this was?
1945 it says,
it doesn't say fifties scarlet Johannson had that whole issue.
Remember she was cast in that movie and it was supposed to be an Asian role in
how,
and people went crazy over it.
Build,
let's hear some of this here.
He goes,
I can't.
Alrighty,
you have telephone.
Wait a minute,
I got your telegram.
I started watching all terrain.
You contact mysterious Mr Raj or pick him up then and she got off the train and
Hodge.
That's one of my man over there.
He and I have,
I owe him seven now around.
Just know you'll follow him.
He couldn't help it.
I think a jewelry we've kept
look at his face.
He does be real look remotely.
They taped his eyes for sure.
They did some weirdness,
but not much because he looks like every housewife in Bev hills minus the facial
hair,
the pullback phase where you're like,
take off 10 years,
but back then,
you know this guy could get away with that.
You know,
uh,
what's his face,
John Lady in the Saran wrap.
She's a ghost or some shit.
Dude.
What's happening to her?
That is bizarre.
Even know if that has to run around back then.
Shit,
I'll bubble
wrap up.
Food is just enough to just on it and take it home after the party balloon.
Put your food inside of it.
It's absolutely saver face.
What is that shit she's wearing?
Like a glass veil or something.
Shiela booth.
Is that Louis Gomez and Shiela booth?
They're time travelers.
And this is,
I mean,
isn't it great to live in this time where our movies are so much better,
but we're going to laugh in the future.
Looking back at how stupid things are today,
you just can't see a comment.
Number one,
you saw have the re look at that guy.
That's a cool chair.
What is that dude?
So another Chinese guy,
that dude,
it's not really a Chinese guy.
I think he's got some terrible face makeup,
I think added to them.
I think that looks like a,
like Joey Diaz on acid.
Look at that with a head wrap.
That's fancy tape.
It does look like.
Takes a regal Tate Tate on acid.
Yeah.
On acid.
Real angry.
Ruling a kingdom after a couple of divorces.
Yeah.
He's like an 80 year old tape.
Yeah,
that's a mental where,
well that's what they used to do.
But look,
look up John Wayne as Ganga is con.
That's even dumber cause they ain't even,
man didn't even change anything,
including the way Todd.
He talked like John Wayne,
we're gonna go out there or we're gonna fuck up these Russians.
He talked literally like John Wayne,
but he was dressed like a for fucking hat on.
It made me cry.
Oh my God,
that's so dumb.
Oh my God.
You have to see it.
How would they made that movie where they're like,
this is it.
This is it.
They didn't know everything sucked.
Everything did kind of suck for sure.
There's only a few like gone with the wind.
Like,
Whoa,
what did they do?
There was like a few movies,
rose citizen Kane like,
whoa.
You're like,
wow,
this one doesn't suck
it up,
gang guess God.
Amazing.
Wow.
Look at that beard.
He went from playing like a fucking sheriff and some wild west.
Wild West town to kingus Khan.
Hollywood was so whitewashed.
It really,
really was.
Well they knew back then.
If they did a John Wayne movie,
they would sell a million tickets.
You know?
That's really what the thing is,
an aspect of that still going on and go on and I sort of,
I don't know if you feel the same way.
I get it to a certain point,
like when you go out in the comedy clubs and there's like a youtube influencer
booked on a weekend,
you're just like,
oh fuck.
But then you're like,
well,
I kind of get it from a business standpoint.
If they're filling the rooms.
I did a Gig in,
in Arizona once and they had a daytime gig books from a youtube influencer.
They pack this place out at 11:00 AM with like 12 year old kids as fans named
Bert Kreischer.
Yes,
it was.
It was a Bert Kreischer day show.
He didn't take his whole shirt off.
It was a crop top or a halter.
Burke does those day shows.
He does.
He'll do radio and then we'll do a show at like noon for people that don't have
jobs.
It's like work call in sick to work or something like that.
You call it something like that.
Like that call in sick to work,
but he took his shirt.
So funny that ladies he's looking slim.
Yeah.
That is slim for Bert.
That's only like 19 months pregnant.
Yeah.
And that's a protrusion in his heart.
He enrolled in the valley bottom eight year old inside of him.
Them has to take his shirt.
He takes his shirt off in the or now every time I used to take a shirt off only
in the main room,
it's like whoa.
Or keep my shirt on now.
No,
he decided no more of that.
Does it come off all every show set right when he gets on stage,
it takes his shirt off.
When you decide when that happens,
I wonder like is there a moment that's how you do it?
Pre,
pre Mike grab or grabs the mic?
Well,
his body is a,
a source of pride.
He enjoys,
uh,
what the fruits of his labor and his,
um,
appetite for,
uh,
indulgence.
I don't know if it's a body as much as it is a building.
It's a body.
People know what's his body.
They know he's a party animal
and they go,
all right,
it's burnt fuck he is.
He's fun.
It is a lot of fun article that was written about that like talking about,
uh,
I was reading this,
this guy was like talking about how hilarious it was.
It's a party.
It definitely has.
I'm sorry.
He is an animal and sometimes you know,
there's this implicit where people are just kind of quiet on stage.
I laugh just by taking off my shirt.
I think I'd go for it.
Why not start off with it?
But now the problem is I think Burt owns it,
which is weird.
You know,
like he's like,
you think he should have some like a little bit of a feeling about it.
No luck.
He owns it.
Like,
uh,
if you wanted to go
up and take your shirt off,
people go,
what do you copy?
That's a good point.
The only one doing it.
He's the only comic disrobing every time.
But there's some weird ones like that Bobby,
Bobby Lee takes his pants off.
I mean,
I've,
I've seen that that weeny weeny a few times winking at me from the green rooms
of the comedies.
You should probably not tell people that first stop doing it.
People probably get mad now.
He can't,
he can't not do it.
They're like,
take off the shirt.
It was a jump on him on stage.
Tag Them.
Yeah.
But I mean there's,
there's a couple of dudes who go clove,
clove lists you take off their pants and their shirts,
but the,
but it's weird that that's Burt's thing.
Yeah,
it is weird.
You're right though.
If anybody else were to do it,
they would know that that was,
uh,
Bert situation.
There was another one like that,
that we were just talking about the other night at the comedy store.
Like how crazy does it someone like took over like a thing,
a standup comedian?
I think so.
It doesn't matter.
I'm not gonna remember.
I want to know what it is.
Well,
there's like a cut.
There's a comic in New York snaps.
You got like a snap every time they did it.
You know what?
Frazier Smith.
I love watching Frazier Smith when he's like,
come on people.
These are jokes and he likes,
yeah,
it's like a,
it's like a timekeeper.
I liked that,
right?
Yes.
In rhythm.
Yeah.
It keeps you in rhythm.
It's,
it's musical up there sometimes if it's going well,
but it goes well.
It's weird how people can become like a thing.
Like this is the guy who talks about food.
I know.
I was thinking about that.
Like how,
what,
what?
What comes first in that scenario,
does it naturally evolve or does it happen once and then the person builds
around it because it's a crutch.
Mm.
There's a,
there's a fine line between the art and the marketing.
Exactly.
Yeah,
and in who you know,
do your thing like it's a short life.
Why not find that little niche that works for you and fucking make that money
and have fun and bring some joy to people who gives a fuck?
I have a problem when people talk shit about people going after what they're
doing and finding a little trick to it.
Who cares what everybody,
everybody's doing.
People get angry if they get tricked God.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
Fucking trick.
Yeah.
Can't believe this shit dude.
I remember there was this lady who reviewed video games,
she was like talking about video games and they found a video of her from years
earlier saying that shows the and play video games.
They're like,
ah,
even play video you're using is like evidence.
I was like,
this is,
this is during that whole gamergate thing,
Mike.
This is evidence that the world has gone mad.
People are arguing over whether or not someone is a real video game player.
You're not even a real player.
You fake play.
We'll have too much time on their hands,
man.
Too much time.
And they get stuck in that like stuck in that like web universe.
Well,
not just that.
Like,
yeah,
people change.
Like I wasn't playing video games just three months ago now.
Jamie and Jeff and I were playing him every fucking day.
We play this quick game.
Oh that's,
that's a video
game.
Jamie fucked me up yesterday.
He beat his ass.
How did that feel?
It doesn't feel good.
Yeah.
We have fun.
We talk a lot of shit.
I was just gonna say you probably talked a lot of shit after you lost.
No.
Did you cry a whole I did.
What he did.
Fuck me up on this one map that I was very angry at this map because it keep
falling off.
That's so whack.
You fall off and you sue us.
He did a much better job than maybe he owned me on the other evens out.
But even so even so I just to a certain degree when the invite,
I liked that one map.
Do we play on?
Cause when you do go out you do suicide but it's not that common.
That other one that was just like every time I get you and if you're jumping and
you don't look behind you,
you're like fuck.
Ah.
You Watch yourself fall explode when you hit the rock
explode.
How many times did it fall is some,
some are the range of 30 not joking.
You're really aren't going to know it.
No.
And here's me fallen.
Fuck goddammit.
Fuck this.
Map this map son of a bitch.
Shit suck.
Suck.
What the fuck.
And then,
uh,
Jeff's getting good to come problem Jeff.
Fuck me up yesterday too.
I think it's good to have like,
I wish I was good at video games.
I'm not,
I'm not that.
What do you wish,
why would you want that skill?
Because I think it's good like the hand eye coordination and just like,
I don't know,
being able to relax,
play game.
I'm going to find a fucking chinuch.
You want to be them drone pilots?
I guess I do.
So what do you think about Ufo owes 100% real?
100% real.
You ever see one?
Um,
I did actually see one really I did in New York City.
This was years ago.
I was walking downtown.
I used to bartend at this place called puppies tavern in Tribeca,
walking downtown.
Beautiful Sunny Day.
And as I'm crossing the street,
I'm just looking at everybody,
everyone's looking up like,
what are these people?
Can I look up?
And there's this like,
I don't know,
like a weird oval chrome thing in the sky pretty far,
far up.
But you could see what it was.
And I was,
I remember talking to the dude,
I'm like,
what is that?
And he was videotaping.
I was like,
I don't know,
we've all been standing here.
It hasn't really moved.
Just was kind of suspended in the air and not a lot of sound at all.
And I had to get to work.
I'm like,
all right,
well I got to go make Calwood cock suckers for investment bankers,
so let me know what happens.
And I went to the bar and it was on the news at the bar and it was just this
weird,
it looked like,
like that bullet,
that little bullet vibrator thing or like a little suppository in the sky.
It was like a like a,
like a balloon.
Yeah.
Like almost like a balloon,
but a little bit more elongated.
Very quiet.
It was bizarre blimp.
Nah,
not like it's sat upright.
It was almost like it.
This was oval shaped Cam.
Exactly right.
But Yup.
It was bizarre.
But that was like the only real time.
I was like,
what is that?
Hi.
I've met,
remember being a little kid thinking that I might've saw something that I might,
I just convinced
myself to sales board.
And also as your memory recalls,
you recreate 100% but what do you remember?
Oh,
I don't remember anything really,
but,
but it was going to say is I've watched this Bob Lasar and area 51 documentary.
Oh boy.
Holy Shit.
It's really interesting.
It's a lot more interesting than I thought.
I always like to like dismiss a lot of the UFO stuff cause the most like this is
nonsense is so silly.
But my friend Dave Foley,
who are,
uh,
I treasure and I value his opinion very highly.
He told me that he started getting obsessed with Ufos.
He said,
thanks to you,
I'm obsessed with you.
I'm like,
thanks to me.
I don't know
system that you might have a lot of obsessions,
I'm sure.
No,
but he and I,
when we used to work together on news radio,
I was deep in my obsession with Ufo.
I was convinced
what kicked it off.
Just tearing people's stories.
If you only had one experience as a kid,
I don't even think I really did have an experience.
I think I probably saw jet fly overhead and like,
I think that might be your fault that I talked myself into it.
I don't think we heard that you had an obsession not based off of your own
experiences.
That's bizarre.
Yeah.
I've always been super,
super obsessed with space.
Yeah.
I think I had a really good teacher in seventh grade science and I remember he
said,
if you really want to make your brain hurt,
just look up and,
and try to imagine something that has no end
verse has no end.
Just you can't,
you want to hurt your head.
Just look up at the sky and understand there's no end to this.
It doesn't make any sense.
Doesn't make any sense because everything else in life and existence has a
finality to it.
Every single thing.
Yeah,
we think,
but this guy,
when he planted that shit in my head,
I remember thinking,
wow,
I never even thought of that before.
Like,
I just looked at the stars and I'll be like,
oh,
there's a stars.
They look cool.
Oh there's the moon are low.
I want to go to the moon.
No.
Yeah,
like a dumb kid.
You don't have the perspective of like the vastness.
Yeah.
But when I was 13,
this guy said that 13,
maybe 14.
No,
12,
I guess 12.
Somewhere in that range.
Seventh or eighth grade.
You had just started at yeah,
I remember him saying that to me.
And then being obsessed with space after that obsessed.
Like one thing that,
uh,
that uh,
the teacher said and that was it immediately.
Like what?
Like that was one of the first cool things I ever heard at school.
You know,
a,
someone cool,
well,
he was a cool teacher.
He was a Vietnam vet.
There was a couple of these guys that were Vietnam vets that were super scary.
There were scary.
It's good to have a teacher like that though.
So many like that whole thing,
like our education system really fails a student.
Sometimes I have teachers who invoke curiosity out of children who actually care
and have a,
you know,
interesting curriculum that they bring to the table.
I only had a couple of teachers like that that I can really remember.
But
yeah,
I think three the three teachers that are really remember that like wow,
that lady was so nice.
Out of your entire schooling.
Yeah,
same.
I had a really cool ms lot.
One was my first grade teacher and she'd have us line up outside of her and she
always had a pop color shall we smelled good.
She always had a pop collar and when you'd walk in her classroom,
if you had a collar,
she'd pop it.
So everybody sat in class and the popped collar.
That's hilarious.
Just brought this like cool mentality.
Like it just,
we felt like we were our own little clan in there.
Like the missalette lot wind clan.
That's what it was like.
When did you know that you want it to be a comedian?
Early,
early on,
like eight years old.
I was young.
Yeah.
I was entertaining my sister.
No,
shut up.
But I didn't know that.
I could make a career out of it because where I grew up,
there wasn't those like outlets there.
You know,
what?
We didn't have like a theater or any sort of cultural exposure that I could,
you know,
adhere to and just be like,
okay,
cool.
I'm going to be no gay people.
That's exactly.
Thank you know gay people.
Well we did.
They were hiding because they didn't want to be murdered.
Lol.
Jk.
Um,
how old were you when you first went on stage?
19.
Yeah,
I was 19 years old.
That's all you had to wait until 21.
I didn't realize afterwards that you can get into a bar as a performer.
I know.
Make sure you don't drink.
Yeah.
There was this cool place called the Cantab Lounge,
which is a,
I mean,
you're Boston,
right?
You know,
you know about all about it.
Cambridge area had this bar called the cantab lounge downstairs.
There was this little performance space called the third rail and I used to do
Improv for like six months and then one of the dudes was like,
you should try standup.
You might,
you might like it.
And this was in Cambridge.
We're doing,
yeah.
That's where I started at stand up and in Boston.
This was an I,
I was 19 I'm 36 now.
I can't do that math.
You're the scientist.
I'm the doctor.
I don't have time to do math.
I have to write descriptions,
calculations about the size of the stethoscope.
I can't do the math.
1919 I don't know what year it was.
2022 years ago.
2006 holy for 23 years ago.
80 years ago.
Fuck you were bad at math.
Just like me.
Well,
it was whatever,
whatever it was.
So you're 36 now,
almost 20 years ago.
Almost 20 years.
And my dad was there.
Actually have on tape.
You have it on tape.
I do have the first time I ever did standup I did and I,
it fucked me up for months,
dude.
It fucked me up for months.
It was just everything you can imagine.
It was new was all the things,
all the little clumsy,
clumsy and fast and not rooted in like a narrative about my life.
It just was sort of a,
a reflection of what I saw.
Essentially,
you go up there and you imitate something until you have your own voice for the
most part.
Yeah,
for sure.
But I have it on tape and I'll never forget,
we even videotaped afterwards and my dad came out from Syracuse to watch it.
My Dad,
he's,
he's since passed in October,
but he came out,
he was there for my first standup show and he's like,
Babe,
you're going to be fine duty.
My Dad's not in the industry.
He doesn't know shit.
This dude was like,
you know,
he sold real estate and bartend.
Like he wasn't like in the entertainment industry,
but he's like,
Babe,
you're gonna be fine.
You're great because you got high energy.
He's like,
you're going to be fine because you're up there and you've got high energy.
That's what the people like.
And I was like,
okay,
dad.
So I just kind of always thought about that like aspect of it,
like just my,
my physicality and not feeling embarrassed by it,
you know?
Did you ever say to your dad,
hey,
what about Steven,
right.
Yeah.
You know,
he definitely,
he liked comedians like that.
My,
one of my dad's favorite comics was a Stan hope.
He loves Stan Hope I'll never forget.
I did a show with Stan hope and Syracuse actually in and,
well,
my dad was sitting next to me when we're watching Stan hope and he leaned over.
He was like,
man,
the mind on this guy.
It's like one of the brightest,
brightest people I've ever heard in my life.
Dads get out more.
He's,
well,
he's,
he's in a grave now.
He's only getting out with a ghost.
He's probably a drunk ghost at some girl's house right now because he can't
find,
mine was getting ready to film another special.
Yeah,
very excited to watch.
it's going to be great.
Stan was,
he's,
he's like the,
I don't know.
He's like the equalizer when it comes to what's going on in society.
It just has a way of being like,
boom,
this is what's going on with gun control and with people being offended by
terminology and words.
Here's why it's ridiculous.
Yeah.
He's good like that.
Well,
he
works,
you know him.
He's a guy that he and he works on his own schedule.
He decides when to write,
when to perform.
When the tour went to do the,
and he was always like,
ah,
I might just fucking retire.
And then right back at it.
New special coming out next year.
Yeah.
He's always,
he's always working.
He's always working.
He has his own glad he's out there.
Yeah,
he's,
he's amazing.
I love watching him.
Glad he's out there cause he's just like,
he's basically an older version of the guy.
He was like 20 plus years ago.
It's has not changed at all other than like become more wacky.
Yeah.
Well it's fucking goofy.
Suits the box and just fucking suits every time I seen him.
What the fuck.
But here's the thing,
like that's one of the things like he owns the no can wear the suit if you wear
a goofy suit,
like a really shitty suit.
Like Stan hope borders,
peach colored suit with ruffles.
He wears loafers like a old man from Caddyshack days.
He looks like he used to sell cars 20 years ago and it kept the outfit.
Yeah.
And I love it.
Frees your Smith's long lost cousin.
He looks up to the 12th Toledo was cousin from Toledo sells cars.
He looks like a ghost from the titanic.
He rents out clown shoes.
Rock star,
those shoes.
Yeah,
but you're right.
That's his,
that's his thing.
Yeah.
That's his look.
No one can do little suits and he's been rocking this look for quite a while
now.
Like he used to dress like a normal person.
Semi.
I mean there was,
there was always a level
of uh,
of eccentric.
His entire wardrobe for $40.
The luxury.
Yeah.
I mean you could get that jacket for $2 and it's amazing.
Then he finds a,
all that seemed to be tailored.
It's like a fraud.
He takes these gay,
he takes these shitty fabrics to like a real high end Taylor.
And he has him like slim fit.
It pretends he finds them.
We definitely get some nice tailored look at that shirt,
the bum jacket,
shirt and tie.
It's not bomb though.
It's all nice and cute and he's nice and clean.
But I'm seeing it looks like a bum that struck it rich real quick.
Like he got money fast and didn't know what to do so we just bought the same
suits but cleaner,
no for bomb struck at rich they'd be wearing like the finest things you saw on
the windows.
Those department stores are on the outside and was in a garbage bag.
Prada,
yeah.
Yeah.
Once you got on your feet and cleaned up and stuff,
couple of days to get used to the fact that you're rich now.
I don't know if I'd be able to.
I obviously I don't have a knack or fashion.
I'm in like a gangster hillbilly overall outfit,
but it works.
I don't know if I'd be able to like just know what to wear after being homeless
for so long.
First you got to kick the heroin and the piss stained shirt.
You got to kick all that.
You've got to clean your body up.
You got $100 billion in the bank now.
Claude,
what's I'm saying there's a little bit of a process,
you know,
you're not going from like shit stain shorts to Gucci Pants.
Well,
most people don't even make it,
you know,
like when when people win money in the lottery,
but they almost always spend it all or go crazy.
I don't think people get adjusted to that idea that all of a sudden boom.
So he just drops off a giant chunk of change.
Like if you got an inheritance,
money from grandpa gives you $1 million,
like you're going to burn through that shit.
Most people,
I don't even think it's reserved for homeless people.
I mean like rappers,
athletes,
comedians.
That's what goes back to our education system.
We're not taught financial responsibility in high school.
We should be,
listen,
it doesn't matter if you teach comedians financing,
most of us are not going to follow that.
Well clunky pulsive I wanted to just at least have something saved for the
future cause I knew that about myself that I did not know enough.
So I started to save some and do a little bit of googling for every Kevin Hart
who has like real knowledge about finances.
There's like four dudes like me.
No idea what's going on that's got like a custom Jim and 16 cars on the way.
I don't have any time for thinking.
But do you like that?
Like what you know as a woman,
you know our indulgences or like you know going to the spa or maybe it's
shopping,
like what's your thing like on a day off,
what do you do that brings you joy?
That is a is a commercial look material and material thing.
Obviously you like your cars and enjoy cars,
but I enjoy,
I'm a big fan of engineering.
Like I'm,
I'm,
I love mechanical things like,
like I think my favorite car,
I have this car that doesn't have any power steering,
it doesn't have air conditioning and it's got an air cooled engine.
It's one of my favorite cars.
What is it?
1993 Porsche,
rs America.
It's a really light car.
Some really even that fast.
It's not fast.
Like a modern college.
It's definitely not fast compared to my Tesla.
Tesla is the craziest fucking car I've ever driven by far.
Every other car seems stupid.
What models seem dumb?
It's the model s just 100 wow.
Fucking postures.
How fast that car is
and just the technology on it.
And does it also have auto?
Oh yeah.
All the drives does everything.
How does that work?
Like if you're driving down the highway,
if you set up auto,
does it legitimately go to your destination?
You have to hit this little thing to switch lanes to see that you want to switch
lanes,
but it'll switch lanes for you.
It will drive with the speed of traffic.
So it'll slow down when traffic slows down,
speed up and traffic speeds up,
it turns,
it makes perfect term.
Wow.
It's crazy.
So could you just be cause see that one out and let it go?
You really shouldn't,
but I'm just as an argument,
you probably could.
Wow.
You hold your hand on
steering wheel.
Like you're supposed to have light pressure on the steam wheel.
Apparently some crazy fucks have a is that's what it looks like on the screen.
Wow.
They just updated it like last week.
Yeah.
The updated to recognize I'm stoplights.
That is so,
I mean the future is now.
That is so wild.
Bananas,
but someone told me,
I don't know if it's true and it's irresponsible for me to even say it,
but I'm going to say it,
do it.
This is your podcast you're looking at.
You're going to go crazy.
Someone said that
you can bypass the touch sensors on the steering wheel that knows if you're
holding onto the steering wheel with a tennis ball.
These shove a tennis ball in there,
and if you do that,
you can just go to sleep
and the try it.
Well,
you know what?
Modern Darwinism.
We'll take care of the rest.
I hope not.
I like
to die either,
but people do dumb things all the time,
but there's a difference between those kinds of cars and the cars that I really
liked.
I liked these mechanical cars.
They feel,
you feel the gears,
like,
see,
this guy's got a tennis ball.
He's got an orange.
Oh Shit in there.
He's got a little citrus.
The citrus works for driving as well as getting rid of bacteria.
Yeah,
he debunked Tesla's autopilot orange hack.
Oh,
he debunked it.
it's to see if it worked or not.
I see.
It seems like it's working and it does look like it's working.
Okay,
so it might explain what you are you,
it makes you hold onto it like every now and then.
It doesn't make you hold onto it all the time as it should fail,
fail,
bunking failed.
It actually does work that way.
I mean,
how much is going on in your life that you can't?
I enjoy driving.
I enjoy the mechanism of it.
I enjoy where my mind goes.
I like blasting my music.
I may or may not hit a joint.
May or may not,
allegedly.
Probably not.
But you know,
I enjoy driving.
Well,
I do too,
but I think if there was a button that you could press,
let's say you drive in the car just drives.
You hit that button the all the fucking time.
Most of the time when you're in traffic,
you just don't want to deal you.
Just,
especially in La,
if I'm going to the airport,
I get up in the morning and I just hate that by
let's go bitch.
Barely pay attention all the way to the airport.
There's certain situations where it would be useful.
Definitely.
But when you're driving,
like say if you're driving in a canyon and you know,
like you're up these hills and driving around these like beautiful scenic
places,
you want to be driving like a little sports car with a manual transmission.
You want to feel it grabbing the wheel and hug in the corners.
Jamie,
there's a care person.
Feel like he,
he can add that to the Tesla.
No.
Why not?
What do you want to feel the gears?
You won't feel the grinding.
You won't feel the shifting of the,
oh,
the gear yourself.
It doesn't have any gears.
Like you're so many oral experiences.
You'd have to be lying to me about,
first of all,
here's one,
the revving of the engine,
like when you get up to red line,
when you're shifting gears,
right?
There's a sound that,
uh,
especially like a really well engineered German car has when they hit those high
revs,
it's uh,
just a,
uh,
it's a symphony of coordinated mechanics.
Why?
And you're shifting and the youth really hit the fucking,
you blip on the downshift.
Like on the downshift,
you do what's called heal towing.
Will you got one foot on the brake and you go like this tomorrow so that as
you're going from third to second,
you give it a little extra juice so that your engine rpm catches up with where
the gears going to be.
When you get into second gear,
it's gonna rev higher,
so wow,
and you're all d.
It's like a coordinated effort.
All these things are happening.
It's not just like sitting there like with an orange on your steering right now.
It's just something else going on.
I just came in my pants from that whole description of
what I'm saying.
If you made fart sounds no,
you can make,
here's the thing.
It doesn't matter if you make the sound.
I want to feel the shift.
They can push the no,
Jamie,
you're pushing your foot into the clutch.
You're putting the thing indicates it's a mechanical action.
You can't fake that.
Now you can't find that given Ilan Ilan can face is going to listen.
If he did,
it would be less good than what he has.
What he's got is better than any other car.
Right.
Cause this basic level of driving,
it's not,
you know,
you're not interactive with shifting and everything,
which is probably the fun of having a car where you can actually drive it
manually.
Well there's a feeling all a bunch of things.
First of all with his car,
they don't have any gears.
It's just one gear.
It doesn't shift.
It doesn't change.
That's bizarre.
It doesn't hit a red line and then you don't have to move to third gear or it
does it itself.
It just has one gear.
And then on top of that it has this giant
navigation screen.
I mean it's the crazy huge fucking thing you've ever seen in your life.
It's like 14 inches tall.
Right.
And then on top of that it's got like all these safety features.
It's looking at things and warning you about this and shows you where all the
cars around you as you're driving.
I was like having my mom in the front seat.
Sounds like just to get something over there.
It's something here.
Watch out for that hunt.
It's like,
all right,
shut up.
What if your mom was psychic in to just sending it to your brain?
Does not saying anything showing it.
It shows that it doesn't like say everything,
but doesn't it have like a fart machine in there?
I read that there's like a fart machine in the and the Teslas.
Oh boy.
You should read more.
I saw.
What was it?
It's a fart sound that it can make if you want it to.
Right.
So when people saw fart machine,
dude,
a fart machine would make actual farts can make it makes a fart noise though,
right?
Yes.
Essentially it's a fart machine.
Just not like a sound effect.
Mechanics deal machine.
There's no machine,
but there's like the,
yes.
That's great.
And that's enough for me to get the Tesla kinds of farts.
Yeah,
you can have like wet forest,
short little tiny farts.
Hookworm farts.
What do you think of hookworm smell like rotten fish.
It carcass.
Some dead worms inside your body.
Like a river soaked carcass.
Have you ever seen an animal?
I know you have a lot of dogs.
Do you ever seen an animal shit out?
Worms.
I know and I definitely don't want to,
but now the images just vivid in my mind.
Many times I'll look worms coming out of there,
but like you look in there but you see like a little worms.
Yeah,
you've ever seen that it's super common.
Crazy that it happened was they have had so many dogs in my life.
That's what does that mean?
That they're like not normal dogs that I haven't had them crap out worms.
Well they probably didn't get dewormed.
You know,
they didn't get their price rescue dogs before.
the deworming stuff takes place.
And when I was a kid,
our dog had it and I remember watching like little worms come out of her,
but I was like,
where is it?
Little white worms with wigs.
And I was like,
what in the fuck is this?
It's nature's weird man.
Oh yeah,
there's an organism feeding on an organism.
That's all.
This is just organisms feeding on each other.
It's one big fuck fest for the organisms or we're leach fest.
These things.
I think the fuck.
Do you think those parasitic worms?
Fuck no,
they just probably separately.
They'd probably just,
you know,
they just divide themselves.
There's no sex happening.
They're like,
it's going to be going a fuck.
Did you see that python that they found in the middle of the everglades?
It was 17 feet long.
My,
I was so I googled it.
I saw,
this is one of the things I was talking about,
exotic pets.
I googled it.
They get to 30 feet long.
I can't.
Something to understand that.
That is ridiculous.
And so then I went down a whole whole direct records,
17 foot long python carrying 73 eggs captured in Florida's everglades.
Another reason we should just get rid of Florida,
snap it off and push it into the ocean.
There's too much craziness happening there.
Fucking snake.
Now here's the thing that freaked me out.
A found of those snakes get twice that length.
So this has only been going on apparently for like the last 15 or so years.
They apparently didn't have a real population of pythons in the everglades 15
years ago,
but somebodies pet get loose.
That thing had 73 eggs.
Oh No.
It didn't get loose.
Some asshole just released his snake.
Someone just chucked it out the window and then it fucks up the balance of the
angle.
They escape from a breeding facility destroyed by Hurricane Andrew in 1992 that
makes sense.
100% Oh,
horror movie starts
horror movie.
Somebody write that script.
Tens of thousands of Burmese pythons are estimated now.
We live in the area and that's just now they've completely wiped out all the
raccoons,
all the skunks,
all the rabbits.
It was almost,
no.
Yeah,
they're eating alligators now.
Nice.
Those things.
Eat alligators video to see the dude.
There's a photograph of one that died because the alligator chewed its way out
of its body.
Nature is so God damn ruthless.
There's some beauty in that ruthlessness,
just that like underlying desire for survival and that exists in creatures like
that,
that can't,
there's no empathy.
There's no sympathy.
They're just going to eat their way out of you to survive.
Yeah.
There's something cool about as long as it's not your five year old kid that
gets snatched up.
Absolutely.
That's a God damn nightmare.
This show this,
but let's just for you guys,
so it was just one doing this.
Look,
that is a different one.
I think this is a,
an Anaconda and a Cayman says python eats alligator alive,
the whole thing alive.
Is that a python?
For sure.
Yeah,
it seems like it is.
It seems like it is.
That's actually a video of me eating a grilled cheese and 2:00 AM looking at
home.
It is sped up a look how it gets all the way down to the fucking tail.
That is amazing.
If snakes have taste buds or if it's just for pure hunger to just stop and think
about what we're looking at here.
This snake just ate a whole alligator tail.
Oh Man.
It's body and it's just going to break it down.
Look at that evil
because they're vulnerable when they eat that he's got to go and just hide it.
Hide under a canopy.
Well,
that's why there's like snakes everywhere on earth.
Well now there are in Florida.
Yeah,
but I mean they're not everywhere because if they,
if they're really could just eat and then go out and eat again like real quick.
Like I'll look how align could it would be,
they would eat it on the ecosystem would be destroyed.
That's the one thing where the alligator chewed its way out
of that alligator.
It looks like the tail popped out and even
see what's going on.
Maybe the tail,
you know,
cause those tails are very strong and they're so thick.
It's like an armor
go to that website.
That's wild man.
Jesus Christ is really wild.
But that's just shows you how hungry these fucking things are.
They've eaten everything that's out there
but also their masters,
their,
their ability to capture something and then kill it.
That's that vicious brought an alligator like those are kind of hard to sneak up
on and capture and hold on to.
I don't think they are.
No,
I think that's one of the reasons why it could get it so quick.
I think they just lay around most of the time.
I think alligators don't tweak because they don't have any natural
and it runs until the pythons came along.
I don't think there's really bad ass.
Oh yeah.
I don't think they're equipped for this.
Yeah,
they're probably not equipped for,
you're probably right where they're just there.
The snake found a vulnerability in the system.
He was like,
I'm going to snack on alligators.
How long it takes a snake with his nasty gut juices to break down alligator
hide.
Three,
three,
three days.
Three to four days.
That's my guess.
I'm gonna say at least a week to break down all of that.
Maybe even longer.
Yeah.
It's got to have some gnarly like
acids in its stomach to break that down.
Some Shit like from the movie alien,
like battery acid.
It just burns right through it.
So why aren't we like using snake acid to break down rust on cars and stuff?
We should be looking into that.
It would clean up,
clean up everything.
An animated recreation of the python alligator battle suggest that the python
might have survived.
It's a massive meal,
but that a second gator came to the rescue and bid off the snake's head.
Oh,
was that the alligators bitch?
No,
the force of the tussle,
the new theory says is what caused the python ghost.
Whoa.
So alligator came and fucked him up after he ate an alligator.
He came and rescued.
They have any homeys no assholes.
I think they're assholes with tiny little brains and they just chew things and
suck them down.
Fuck reptilian style.
Did you ever see that video of the crocodiles and they go to feed them and uh,
it was on my Instagram.
Jamie,
the one with the crocodile.
This lady goes to throw some chicken out for the crocodiles and the crocodile
snap up the chicken and one crocodile reaches over to the guy next to him and
bites his leg,
bites the crocodiles like and it just rolls,
snaps it off,
checks it down,
swallows it.
And the other alligator,
the other crocodile rather,
it doesn't even budge.
He just got his arm bid off.
He's like,
what happened?
Oh my fuck.
This is when you realize what these things are.
They don't give a fuck there.
It's so crazy to watch.
Doesn't even freak out that its arm got bitten off and swallowed by it.
I will say if I'm eating really delicious sandwich and someone bites me,
I'm gonna be like,
I'm just going to finish the sandwich.
I have to be honest.
How hungry are you if you're very hungry?
Well,
he's not even been finishing.
He's lying there and the other allergy or these other crocodile bites
his leg and then rips it off.
Watch this shit.
Just watch it.
Boom.
Now Wash,
they run in.
See this one's snacking up and grabs it and the watch gator roll death.
Snaps it off,
chucks it down.
Go.
But look at him.
He doesn't even do anything.
Well what the fuck bro?
He just lost his leg and he's like,
what the fuck bro?
I mean those are not regenerative,
right?
Yes they are.
Can he grow another pot?
Yup.
Whoa.
Yeah,
they,
they grow other pots all the time.
That is so wild.
When it's insane or DNA,
my face.
I bet you that's really good for just like keeping your shit fresh or you look
like scales.
You want that.
That'd be kind of cool.
Forever scales.
That'd be a superhero I could probably capitalize on it.
Not even have to worry about what you look like.
Right.
Just scales to your face to there.
Right now,
I'm not going to wear any rouge.
I got scales.
I'm a go out.
Some girl had to be the first girl.
Get a face tattoo.
You can be the first girl.
He get scales.
Probably some.
Probably really long time ago somebody just got a face tattoo.
Well most likely,
most likely try tribal.
Maybe like one of those polyandrous tribes.
What does this Jamie,
so what?
It looks like a snake with the alligator inside of it.
It does take three days for it to break down.
[inaudible] scientist assignments to your lane at her.
Watch out.
I'm a doctor and a scientist and you know all about gut acids.
I know about gut acids cause I'm Italian.
I've got Agita.
God just didn't forever.
That's the silliest science.
He's got the fucking ige.
Know what's crazy about the everglades is if this is how it is now,
imagine what it's going to be like 20 years from now when these things just keep
breeding.
It's going to take a few generations for that to balance back out.
They need to put some walls in that area and get it all back to where it should
be.
Well,
they have crocodiles in there now too.
There's been confirmed sightings of Nile crocodiles,
not American crocodiles.
Nile crocodiles for the same reason.
That's wild.
Yeah.
The alligators are,
that's fucked.
It's fucked because those are the ones that eat zebras and shit.
Everything they're going to be eating,
watch,
hide.
Your kids hide your wife.
They don't definitely,
they'd be raping everybody.
Remember that guy?
He,
this is what I'm saying.
He found a lane and he capitalized off of that little moment.
He did for a little bit.
Yeah,
for a hot minute and now we know who he is by just saying a phrase.
I met him.
I met him at a,
one of the UFC is,
oh,
that's wild.
How was he?
A gentleman.
Very nice guy who's super confused about his life,
like fuck is going on here.
Why am I here?
Everybody knows me.
Like you went from being just a regular guy talking about break ins.
He was on the news interview to do it on the news and he was so funny that he
came back a viral star and then next thing you know like Dana white flew him out
to the UFC.
We were hanging out with him backstage is like,
what is this life?
Wow,
how about that?
Like cash me outside girl.
She is a,
she's a,
she's a rapper.
She's got like 20 million followers on Instagram and she's wrapping giant
billboard on sunset buildings where they have the whole thing about body but bad
baby bed bed.
Bit bitty bitty IBEW payments.
But you know,
sometimes when I work out I put female rapper station on Spotify and she pops
up,
look at his hair now,
live in your truth and love it.
Hold on a second.
Formerly gay.
Yup.
Antwan Dodson announces his baby boy's birth after expressing this desire to get
married.
That was a confusing headline,
but live it.
Do it.
He formerly get,
well,
you know,
he looks great there.
You should be open to change people who should be,
uh,
do you think that someone can be gay and then they could switch over?
Absolutely.
And they stopped being gay and they start being attracted to women.
Why not?
We're,
we're on a dot suspended and nothing that's expanding.
Why not?
That's so stunning to think,
right?
Like what is that possible?
Because I think what you just said,
people exist.
Some people exist in these comfortable bubbles and they have their routines and
they fear change because of the exhaustion,
because of what it takes.
And then when they hear somebody else live in a life that's outside of their
little bubble regimen,
they freak out because maybe it reflects their own inability to change
themselves or their fear of changing.
So I think a lot of that where people like,
you know,
look at someone like Antwan Dotson who was in a wig and where's glip gloss?
Or like,
what's that?
First of all,
you don't know that's a wig.
That's hurtful.
Did I trigger you Harrison Harris?
Beyonce.
It's really,
I think the same thing when I wake up.
It's real too,
by the way.
That's a real woman.
Okay.
Respect.
Better.
Watch out.
Those hips will snap.
You can turn on people that way by bringing something up that they didn't even
say and then saying,
don't ever fucking say anything about her,
but I didn't.
You're like,
what are you talking about?
All of a sudden you're on the defensive.
Be careful of people like that though.
I know what you're going to say next.
You're going to say yes,
that's mental illness.
You're going to say the Donald Trump is a strong leader.
What times?
I'm going to say that you're like,
wait a minute.
You got to say that we need border security.
I know.
What the fuck do a racist like,
no,
no.
I have a conversation here.
I mean,
we need some border security.
Don't we blocked off.
We'll go down that wormhole with crazies.
Did you ever see what the board,
it looks like in Canada,
the middle of the forest,
I would imagine like Maple Syrup fountains of it's paved.
It's like not paved.
It's,
um,
it's like trimmed.
All the trees are trimmed and wide.
There's like a path that's a hundred yards wide.
That was like the border between us.
Like say if this table was like baron,
there's forest on this side of the force on that side.
That's what the path is like the entire length of the,
the connection between the United States and Canada.
That's trippy also.
Did you just call me?
No,
I didn't.
I said it's barren.
I was like true.
Probably.
That's wild.
Have you seen it in person?
No.
No,
no.
I just found out about two weeks ago.
That's really cool.
Crocodiles apparently can't regrow their limbs.
Oh,
that's a bummer.
Are you sure?
I just looked it up.
Even their tails.
Other amphibians,
Canva,
crocodiles and alligators can't,
I guess they're not going to live without a limb or two,
it says,
but they can't regrow tens of bomber.
You would think they would because you would think like genetically there's
similar like salamanders.
Couple of websites.
I mean I'm not,
I'm not the scientist here.
We know you aren't because he's sitting right here.
I'm not assigned to see that.
There can't be too soon to have something though.
It sounds good.
You're a doctor of comedy.
There's only that true.
Wow.
That just looks like a a power line path down to out.
It looks like cocaine.
It doesn't like a big line.
No,
no touchy zone.
I have the no touching zone.
Two zone right there.
That's my,
it's all my zones.
Isn't that crazy?
That's the border between the beautiful.
That's beautiful.
If you go up there and that is God's country,
that is spectacular.
I would love to blaze a blunt and walk that whole fucking thing.
It will freak you out.
Do you ever go a hiking deep in where you've got no cell phone reception and you
get to,
I not like where it's that deciduous,
but like in,
you know like Jude deciduous,
second big Joe Rogan.
I am somewhat well read.
I'm a fucking doctor.
Oh,
I forgot you were a doctor.
You have a doctor.
I was like to be a doctor of something.
What do I feel you're a doctor of?
I feel you're a doctor of comedy for sure.
We'll have it though.
There's no,
there's no,
I know there's no mastery.
We,
you and I've talked about this before and you know,
I said something like,
I don't know,
you were like,
how's comedy?
I'm like,
I'm just trying to figure it out.
You're like,
none of us ever will.
I,
I'm not saying that like you're the end of it,
but I think I was watching you on stage at the comedy store in,
in Hinchcliffe was next to me.
And um,
you know,
you're doing your set Killen and having a,
having a great show and this woman yells out in the middle of a joke and you
just kept fucking going.
You are so disciplined.
You didn't miss a beat.
You didn't acknowledge her.
You didn't give her any sort of energy or attention.
You just were so like in your joke.
And I just looked at Tony and he was like,
I know everybody else would have went to her a VA,
you know,
totally just like abandoned their joke and messed up the flow.
But you just,
in that day I was like,
damn,
I need to,
I need to stick to my jokes more than like indulging people who are yelling at
me from the office.
Sometimes you have to indulge it and sometimes they are also going to ruin it
for the people around them.
That's the number one thing to like when people go you,
you just can't fucking hang.
Like people have said that to like Chris Leah.
There was this lady called him.
What did she say?
She goes,
you're a planner,
not a comedian.
A real community and can deal with someone yelling something out.
Okay.
Chris told her,
shut the fuck up and get out of there and they kicked her out and that was her
thing that you're a planner.
And so now that I'll text Chris deleo nowhere.
You're a fucking plan.
Or Bro,
he such a planner.
Comedians are the most unorganized people ever.
If anything,
they're the worst planner.
Sometimes you have to address them.
Sometimes you do.
The real problem is that there they're fucking it up for the people around them.
They think they're just,
they're interacting with you.
But did not take any consideration the fact that even if you don't like what
someone's saying,
let them say it because there's 300 other fucking people in the room and you,
you don't get to the side.
You don't have to program director.
Right.
You don't get to decide what you like or don't like it just because you're in
front of that person.
You yell something out.
If the whole audience is sitting there watching the performance and the guys
working his way through some material there,
or the woman,
by the way,
sorry.
Um,
let them fucking finished their shit,
man.
Do you find you have which gender yells out more or is it equal?
Oh,
it's equal.
It's just dumb.
Equal men to women.
Most women.
Really?
Yeah.
I'd say for me it's been like 95% women
probably say
maybe there's a little bit of a,
an advanced and a little bit of a numbered difference in favor of men doing it.
Obviously you probably have a more male dominated audience than I would.
Yeah.
But guys bring their girlfriends and girlfriends like fuck him.
Listening to them,
always listening to him.
He's a fucking idiot asshole.
Do you really believe what he's saying and enough people just listen.
You can get confused and think you know what the fuck you're talking about.
That's what he is.
That's exactly what he is.
Just cause a lot of people are listening to him doesn't mean he knows what the
fuck he's talking about and you worship him like,
oh my God,
do you love him?
Are you in a bromance?
Is that what's going on?
You should be embarrassed of your side.
I don't give a fuck with Joe Rogan real man bringing that up.
God isn't even,
he's disgusting.
He's very angry.
He looks like a man ape ill
also the appeal is that you look like a Manny.
Well I get it gals.
I don't want to listen to fucking Taylor swift songs either
tear on my car and she's like,
Hey,
it is going to hate you.
Rock out to Taylor.
A few songs that are not bad.
You've got daughters in your house.
I know you dance to a Taylor swift.
I probably have if I've been hammered.
The thing is it's like it's not my thing.
It's not like
what I would listen to all the time.
Like it's not my go to,
you know,
and people have different go,
tos doesn't make it right or wrong,
but if you get dragged into someone else's Goto,
he got a grant and Barrett,
you ever,
anybody ever take you to a musical?
Jesus fucking Christmas.
It's,
it's a,
it's a thing.
I went to one musical,
I went to like three musicals.
One of them I only went to,
cause Stamos was in it due to do is tell everybody.
Jessie may might have a bit of a stock issue with giant Dockery.
I am not.
Stalking is a very nice man.
He reached out to me when my father passed.
He was very nice to me.
He sent a message.
He was very,
very nice.
Well,
but all joking aside,
you do
have about a hundred photoshops of you with John Stamos in various positions in
bed on a plane together,
on vacation together.
I'm sorry Katelyn,
who um,
my fans make,
you know,
they super impose me.
I find a photo of his,
it's funny and I'm like,
put me in this.
There's white horse,
he posted a picture of him on bed,
like from like the full house era.
I was like,
somebody put me on the bed
and then I apologize to Katelyn.
I always apologize to his wife and child.
I mean for the most part I try to joke,
but it's a long running joke that you've been doing for years now.
Are you kidding me?
Like I loved him as a kid and I,
I told this story before,
but I have a,
I had a poster of him above my bed as a kid that I literally kissed so much.
I wore a hole in his mouth.
Oh,
through Joe Rogan.
did you ate through the paper reading the tongue.
We are looking at
doing all of the things.
Okay.
All of the things.
Yeah.
But I,
I went to a musical,
he was in bye bye birdie.
Very delightful.
Very talented man.
And then I went to a couple others,
but they are,
I fell asleep and the other ones,
they're ruthless.
They're,
it's in the intermission.
Kills me.
It's like,
why don't we just get it done?
Let's just go straight through.
Yeah.
I think I would've liked to see the book of Mormon that's like,
oh yeah.
You know,
that's,
that's a,
that's the exception.
I saw that.
It's awesome.
Yeah,
I would imagine they're geniuses.
Those guys are geniuses.
Yeah.
It's just really well read to a really well written rather.
It's really funny.
It's a really good story in there.
They obviously did their homework,
but I saw cats once when I was on a date.
I was Pawlak 19 fuck that.
Fuck.
Cats in general who are scary in real life.
Why you want to go see him sing and they're standing upright.
That's a nightmare.
You're a dog person,
not a cat person.
I would like a hairless cat.
Oh,
like a spanx.
I think they're cool.
The Shit in a box in your house.
Perfect.
So do I piss in your house?
I'm going to change my toilet to be Roman.
Fuck you.
I'm going to shit in about a bucket.
Yeah,
they shit in a box.
But that's a great thing to grow.
Sometimes my dog's crap on the carpet if there,
you know,
irritable.
The cats are weird,
man.
Cats.
I don't know if you can trust a cat.
Did you try some cats?
You have a couple cats,
don't you?
Yeah.
You got a fucking zoo.
I'm so jealous.
I want to come over and just put everything in your house.
Who am I?
Dogs died recently.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I guess it was probably almost a year now.
It was Marshall said,
uh,
he didn't understand what was going on.
He looks like he's just pure joy and happy all the time.
He's the happiest dog.
He's so,
he brings me joy.
I just started following him on his true.
He's so happy.
Follow your dog on Instagram.
He's my buddy.
He's,
he's,
it's so weird.
Like you can see you guys have a straight bond.
Let's see.
So affectionate.
Do you run them off leash in the morning when you go?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
No tickets.
You know,
he's been,
um,
he's got tick medication that he's taking,
but we have caught him with a couple of ticks home without all that luxurious
hair.
Those ticks are Pi like woo is struck,
match.
He,
he loves it though.
He never seen anything in is
pure joy as that dog is like riding through the canyons.
He just loves it.
He's so happy.
So how do you keep him so clean?
I mean,
I know you've got that like Joe Rogan experience money,
but he is luxurious cold water
and I've seen these mangled piece.
They really don't.
And they wonder why they lash out.
Marshall's not like for cats.
When you die castle start eating your face and like 16 hours dogs wait about a
week.
Yeah,
they probably don't even wait that long.
Dog stay about a week.
They love you a little bit more.
They won't eat you right away.
I don't even know if Marshall would eat you.
I think he would wait.
Wouldn't even know what you were.
Probably wouldn't understand it.
He would just keep throwing balls at you.
Just rolling them over to you whine.
He woke me up yesterday.
It was fucking really annoying.
Just decides to get up.
I got home from the comedy store,
I'd like to,
and then I watched some goofy,
I've been on this Ufo documentary kick watching you a foe.
Documentaries.
I told you it was David started talking about it.
We were talking about that.
What were you,
did you have something specific that you had saw a recently the documentary,
one of them was air area 51 Bob Lasar and Lef area 51 and flying saucers.
Some,
a documentary on this guy who claimed that he worked on these alien ships in
area 51 in the 1980s as time's gone on,
more of the things that he said if proven to actually be true,
including an element that he talked about.
Element one 15,
I think it was called like an organism from outer space.
No,
no,
no.
An element like a man created element,
you know,
at this carbon will,
there's an element that they created that he talked about way before it was ever
publicized and he talked about this thing and then it turned out to be true.
He talked about these,
um,
there's these,
uh,
hand monitors that you would put your hand on this thing and these lines,
these metal lines would detect the distances in the bones of your fingers,
the exact distances and everyone is different.
It's like a signature thing and that they could find out if it was you or not
you,
it was trying to go through.
So the way they would scan people that bioscan would literally measure the bones
in their fingers and people said that was horse shit.
He talked about this in the 1980s people said it was horseshit but then later on
turned out no,
they did have that.
And Los Alamos,
they did have that in,
in area 51 and that this technology was very,
very uh,
advance,
very,
not just at very advanced but very not,
it was not well known at all.
Like very few people did.
And this guy who was creative of this documentary,
it was very difficult for them to get photos of this hand scanner.
But this hand scanner did exist and existed exactly as this guy described it in
the 80s I mean that's super progressive for that time.
It was also that did approve is top secret clearance to get to this place.
They know that he actually worked there.
There's people that worked in the same Los Alamos lab with him.
They tried to say he never worked there,
but his name's on the manifest.
It's very strange.
It's like they've tried to erase parts of this guy's passed because he um,
he filmed a bunch of their crafts as they were flying around.
Like he knew what days.
This is the thing,
that thing right there,
you put your hand on that and it actually measures the distance of the size and
length of your bone.
That's,
that looks like something that's inside of an escape room in La.
I went into this documentary,
skeptical.
Yeah,
what I am,
I'm so done with all those things but listen to this guy talk for awhile.
After awhile I was like,
what if he's telling the truth?
Like what if he is actually telling the truth because if he's actually telling
the truth,
there is some part of the government that had access at least in the 1980s to
alien technology.
I mean it is,
it probably is some truth to that.
Crazier things have happened and also like just your mentality of believing him.
It's probably the same thing that made Dr Malakai Lovejoy Robinson,
the third become successful con artist.
Yeah.
I mean either this dude,
there's validity of what he's saying in this documentary,
which I can't wait to watch or he's just really great at painting a picture.
Some people are so good at convincing you that's true of truths.
True.
There's people with like borderline personality disorder in every sort of
spectrum in between there they become really good manipulators.
That is true.
However,
usually they do that in more than one avenue.
Absolutely.
And this guy's not doing that.
Yeah.
So it's just a documentary.
Then also hasn't varied a story.
I mean he might have like changed the way he says things in terms of the words
he chooses,
but the actual story is exactly the same as he was telling a long time ago.
Is this a self produced documentary or is there a production company?
Production company.
That's where it's like,
okay,
there's probably some validity to this.
Yes.
This guy's been around for a long time.
I remember reading about him and watch videos about him,
you know,
20 years ago.
I mean,
don't you think you're somebody who,
you said you,
you know,
and I know this about you,
you love space.
You're,
you're obsessed with that.
The idea of what we are in,
in the solar system and beyond,
like how impossible is it to think that there could be a creature that could
breach our atmosphere with some advanced technology and be able to just sort of
chill,
you know,
scoot around,
scoot scoots Magoon's check us out and fucking piece out,
back up to wherever they're from.
I don't think that's how they would do it,
but yeah,
I know what you're saying.
Exactly.
They schools,
schools.
Yeah.
They just kind of cruise around.
You know,
they're looking at us.
Well,
he had an interest or common sense.
He said,
if you brought a,
um,
uh,
an atomic engine to these people that live in the Victorian era and said,
hey,
this is a,
this is a nuclear power plant,
like here,
here,
check this out.
They would fuck with it.
They'd wind up getting sick from radiation.
They'd wind up dying.
No one would understand what it was or how it worked.
They would never figure it out.
Right.
He goes,
why would we assume that this is
only from that one time with this one device?
Why would we assume that there'd be some other technology that maybe we'll
create some day in the future?
I'm paraphrasing him very poorly.
Or someone else from another planet would create that we wouldn't understand at
all and he said that's what we were dealing with when we're trying to back
engineer the propulsion systems that these things use the,
they use some gravity based propulsion system and it was just something that
would manipulate gravity in front of it's very,
look,
I don't,
I'm too stupid to know the science of it.
I don't know if he's like,
if you were a scientist you're supposed to know I have to get my degree,
get a degree so I can call us.
You should just want to get an honorary one.
Like Cosby Hud.
It's gone now.
He doesn't have a honorary ones.
They can take back.
You can't keep that.
Actually I think he wrote an essay and that's how they gave him his doctorate
and that's neither here nor there.
Probably got more than one doctorate.
Sherry did and he did.
It didn't deserve them.
But I think,
I mean there's gotta be stuff out there.
Oh,
a hundred percent a hundred percent but I like to say there's not,
it's like,
ah,
stop.
No,
no,
I don't think it is,
but it is entirely possible.
Um,
I use that phrase too often and it's entirely possible.
You've got to get a mash up of all of those.
It's of out there hilarious.
150,000 of them
to be uninsured.
It's possible that we're the,
we're the most advanced.
That's possible too because something has to be the most advanced.
Absolutely.
And something has to be the least.
We could also be on that part of the spectrum or maybe where the last two we
evolve.
It's a hundred percent a hundred percent possible.
And if there's,
if there's an infinite number of life forms out there,
like if there's an infinite number of planets and there's an infinite number of
earth,
like planets that could know have beings like us on it,
who's to say that we're not the most advanced?
Maybe they're all like people from the 1820s.
They haven't caught up to the ceiling shit.
They're still doing,
you know,
I don't think they chiseled chisels,
but I'm talking like old old shit.
They don't even have pens and papers yet.
Like the Orangutan.
It was fishing with a spear.
Exactly.
There's just a bunch of advanced orangutans that are like,
you know,
putting hieroglyphics and caves.
It's possible.
It's totally possible because we're just,
we're just basing it off of our own experience and perception of what we have
been exposed to.
The other,
um,
really interesting scenario is that there are time travelers,
oh,
that's exciting to think about are,
is some being from the far distant future that understands that it could come
back and observe us and see like where things went wrong,
where things went right,
but do so in a way that's as minimally intrusive as possible and occasionally
interfere.
That's things that gives me chills.
That freaks me out once you start fucking with time and our perception of it,
how it exists
in like being able to hop along that spectrum of,
it freaks me the fuck out.
There's this movie I saw called a ghost story and it's not a horror movie.
It's kind of about that.
It's a Casey Affleck and Rooney Mara,
I think.
Rooney.
Rooney Mara.
It no ghost.
I Ms. Patrick Swayze.
He's so much.
I miss him.
He's one of those actors.
I love.
If you could bring Patrick Swayze back and and take away your full house boy,
who dare you.
What's his name again?
Joseph Nathaniel Rogan.
I don't know.
I mean that's a tough call.
I mean,
Swayze gave us,
he gave us dirty dancing.
He gave us a look at that.
What a beautiful man.
He could move those hips.
Those when he was a surfer,
that was point break.
He was the rebel surf.
Do do you remember the video on Sarah at live of him and Chris Farley doing the
Chippendales audition?
Iconic.
That's iconic comedy.
That is like such a great crossroads between beauty
and Chris Farley.
Chris Farley put it all out on the table during the sketch.
It is so funny,
Miss,
I really do Ms. Patrick Swayze,
but I Crucey that he was so fit.
But yeah,
he smokes cigarettes.
He did it.
Did he really probably have cancer.
He probably smoked cigarettes to stay fit.
Some people get stuck in that,
you know they are afraid of letting it go because they think it helps with their
physique and in maintaining the look on a models.
Do that.
Staying skinny.
Yeah.
Cause you know it's a,
it's an upper increases your heart rate and all that and whatnot.
It also kills your appetite.
I think.
Totally kills your taste bud.
You can't taste anything.
Everything is destroyed.
Maybe you should smoke.
That's the only way you should look at us is by smoking cigarettes.
They don't taste it like you have to.
You have to choose God.
This is brutal dude.
You're making me lose Stamos and get hookworm.
I'm just saying stay.
Most are Swayze stamus all day bro.
Stamos for life.
Sorry Swayze.
See on the other side will be,
and I will be messaging you later.
Stop for a moment.
Really reconsider what you're saying.
Think about the great films Swayze provided us with.
Okay,
I will bitch.
All of mankind's entertainment falls on my shoulders.
Road House also,
you know,
I know now.
I feel bad.
When you look at his IMD be posted for Roadhouse,
you're either going through 10 seasons,
a full house or roadhouse
roadhouse,
dude.
Okay.
And selfishly it's Stamos split on an overall spectrum and Swayze all time for
mankind.
I will.
I'm sorry Kaitlin.
I'm going to have to go with Swayze Swayze all day.
That's what we said we're going to start doing.
Jamie is doing,
I'm like fight companions for like terrible movies.
Oh,
Swayze again.
Stamos we should get barbecued and place showgirls
25th anniversary.
You have to,
people don't even know,
Dude.
Showgirls is a cult classic.
It's an amazingly bad movie.
It's so epically bad.
It's kind of like what?
What?
How I felt when I watched the dirt recently.
It ended this Gal's career.
It did it basically.
No,
not at all,
didn't it?
No.
Did she take off after that?
She stayed.
She stayed pretty plateau,
but she was the,
she was on her way to being a gigantic superstar.
She's The star of this movie.
She's super hot.
She's half naked.
She took this movie.
I'm speculating,
but I thought she took this movie because,
because it was going to be the next thing and ended up being such a such a
brutal failure that maybe,
I don't know.
It's so good.
It's so bad.
It's good.
It's crazy.
And it's got great actors in a two [inaudible] clock.
A great actor.
She's not a Christian.
I have a bad actress.
She was amazing.
She was in bye bye Birdie with stay Molson on Broadway.
What's the cast who scroll back all the way up to the top?
That is a great case.
Go to all,
not just images.
I mean her body was amazing in this,
obviously it's kind of like,
um,
number to me more.
When she did that stripper movie as well,
she was a GI Jane.
She was amazing in Gi Jane,
but didn't do me more,
do a stripper movement part Gij,
Elizabeth Berkley and my favorite part in Geo James,
when she says,
suck my Dick.
I was like,
hmm,
I need to put that on a tee shirt.
No,
just she said suck my Dick.
And then,
yeah,
she was like on her way to being a navy seal.
That's great.
General Gi Jane,
she's going through bootcamp.
I remember those like
triptease
Dude Demean Moore's body and strip tease was all the things she was so bang in
that movie.
She's so beautiful.
I just from,
I mean we be burned into your head.
It's just one of those movies that I remember she was,
she was like jacked in that movie and in dancing very awkwardly.
The very awkward stripper dance that happened.
I just going on with that outfit.
It looks like she belongs on a wedding cake.
Something on a television show or tonight show.
It was like Telemundo.
What do you think she's doing these days?
Some people get super,
super famous where they're everywhere and then they go,
I'm done.
I think she's just chilling.
You think so?
I hope so.
I hope she's just chilling and just Kinda,
you know what?
What?
Was she going to do?
Another movie?
Maybe?
Maybe in India?
Absolutely.
She maybe she should do,
I don't know.
It would tap into a different
era.
We haven't seen.
Give me where she's good,
where she is.
I she's taking a break.
You know,
we got a couple of projects on the table.
I don't know what she's going to do.
I don't know either.
Who's didn't expect you to like defend yourself
and I'm like,
no one's pressuring me.
Jessie Mae who is marijuana?
You're still high all I've been high for four days.
Oh,
who's your celebrity crush?
I don't have one.
You don't know.
I'm good.
You don't have like a,
like a fantasy,
you know like a fantasy chick.
Maybe Madonna from the 80s wow.
She was young.
Bold choice.
Pointee bra was also,
you know that she was never going to get hooked on.
You should take off.
He'd be able to go
take care.
I liked her because she knew she wouldn't like me.
I knew she wouldn't like me for long.
That's a real strategy that men,
some men employed like this one's not going to last.
It's great.
That's an honest answer.
It really is.
Yeah.
That's the,
that's the allure of the positive,
independent woman.
Powerful,
positive,
independent woman.
It was like,
she's just not nice.
It's not needy at all.
She's like,
yeah,
well see ya.
There she is dirt
from the,
that's all real too.
It was notes from her closet for sure.
She's in like dudes briefs and some like doilies on her legs and apparently she
learnt though.
Fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
Like to Smash said Warren Beatty.
Sean Penn to see this movie that these,
this is the three identical.
These are the twins or the documentary is about,
you haven't seen three identical strangers.
No,
I heard it's amazing.
I almost brought it up the other day cause you guys started talking about
something,
I forget what podcast it was,
that this movie sort of bleeds into not spoiler alert because this movie's power
genetic testing type shit back in the day,
like in the,
in the 50s right.
They were doing it like in the fifties and sixties in an in like an orphanage.
Yeah.
I need to find some time to watch that because everybody recommends it.
Just when you think like a revelation happens and you're like,
what the fuck?
And then another one happens,
you're like,
this has got to stop.
And then you're just like,
holy hell.
And then it's just a thing where if somebody wants to get something done,
sometimes they take really drastic measures.
It's selfish and it's terrible and it breaks all ethical,
you know,
rules.
But I don't know there could they do it?
Well,
we're spoiler alert out for a while.
Do it as an experiment on these guys on purpose.
There's a psychologist who wanted to find out stuff
running an orphanage in withholding information from the families to find out
how it would work out.
What they were doing was nature versus nurture.
They were,
they were seeing what affects it has on a child.
Um,
based on how it's raised by also by the socioeconomic status of the family,
about the neighborhood.
It's in,
about the type of unit,
the love,
all of those factors and what results it has on the individual.
Right.
What don't you say,
Jamie?
That's kind of the data.
They have a bunch of data apparently somewhere and it never came out.
It's missing,
it's gone.
The files are just gone.
Disappeared years of them basically ruining the lives of children and the
effects of that is just dissipated into thinner.
It's such a,
it's such a heartbreaking story,
but it's also very interesting.
And that's what I'm saying,
like how would you ever,
not that that needs to happen,
but there is a question.
I mean,
you're a father,
right?
I mean we could look at like all the things that are happening in society,
especially with like mass shooters and people who commit these random acts of
violence and go back to their upbringing and their rearing.
I'm pretty sure I would take a gander and a guest that they probably weren't
raised with the most amount of love.
There's certain things that you don't really know how it's gonna work out until
you experiment.
Yeah.
And that's what I was saying,
like it's a little brutal,
but what people are scared of,
that kind of thing.
Cause that's where Hitler came from.
That kind of thinking about some of the experiments they did on people.
Man,
that was just scary.
Doctor supposedly I think came in with the operation paperclip.
Oh Jeez.
Oh my God,
that's hard.
It's,
it's pretty fucked up.
it's,
you know what operation paperclip was?
Well,
isn't that something like a Hitler thing back in the day with babies?
No,
no,
no.
It was the Nazi scientists that were taken from World War II,
so the United States took Nazi scientists,
including Warner von Braun,
who was the head of NASA,
a bunch of other scientists and all these Nazis that were working for Germany
making rockets and involved in like high level science.
I never brought them over to America and sort of whitewash the whole thing.
They called it operation paperclip,
Holy Werner.
Von Braun.
When he was at the head of NASA,
he was a fucking legitimate Nazi,
like the Simon Wiesenthal Center,
so that if he was alive today,
they would prosecute him for crimes against humanity.
I feel like there's still,
you know,
there's still a sprinkling of people in there that sort of Dave chase these guys
down to the far ends of the earth and a bunch of them.
Those are very powerful positions to be in,
to have that sort of mentality driving it.
That's scary as fuck for sure.
You know what's really crazy is Argentina,
Argentina,
and South America a lot.
And Nazis went to Argentina and South America.
They fled Germany.
And Tim Kennedy,
who's a good friend of mine,
who was a former UFC fighters,
a soldier,
he was on a show called finding Hitler,
where there was,
there's been speculation over the years because so many Nazis landed in South
America that Hitler had escaped and lived out his life in,
in,
you know,
protected by these other Nazis.
And these South American towns,
there's towns in South America too.
There's towns in South America where they,
all they do is speak German.
They have October fast.
They have photographs on their walls of their grandfather in ss garb.
That is very,
very scary.
Oh dude,
it's crazy.
He blew me away when he was telling me about this and,
and that.
He's a no nonsense guy.
So when he's explaining,
he's like,
you've got to understand you're coming into these towns.
Everyone is German.
Oh my God.
They all look like Germans.
They all talk German.
They all have German like houses and German,
like German style stuff in their house.
This bizarre fucking crazy.
What happened?
I don't know.
No,
it's maybe not what happened to Hitler,
right?
They're pretty sure the Hitler died,
but I'm sure they relocated it.
That's definitely what happened.
They said,
see if you can find that.
Jamie will find something that will blow you away.
This is just a South America look.
It looks like a German town,
Dude.
It's crazy.
There's a whole village of these fucking people and there's not just one.
There's many,
many of these little little pockets that looks like an October bar.
That's really bizarre.
I mean,
that one looks a little Japanese that well,
there's videos though.
It's really crazy.
They're drinking out of steins and like the whole deal means are really wild,
dude.
It's crazy.
Obviously we couldn't get them all.
I mean,
they had to flee somewhere and they're going to set up shop,
make it there.
You know,
make it,
they're homogenous.
They saw the shit was about to hit the fan and said,
listen,
I know a place we can get some cool Margarita's.
We can catch some fucking toast.
South America,
South America.
That's a wild.
I never knew that.
Oh,
it's,
yeah,
I didn't know it either.
It's crazy.
It's really crazy.
I see.
Man thinks is too much to know.
There is too much snow,
but it's one of the great things about the stuff you talk about on this is you
got to it,
but just like a plethora of information.
Useless.
Most of it's useless.
It's useless.
Wasted wasting time.
You know what?
I'm going to do anything with it,
dude.
I've been taking CBD with THC.
Oh,
that's great.
He delivers it.
Got a bit of a problem.
What's the matter bill?
I've been high every day for the last six days.
I pop these little uh,
tablets in the morning.
It's CBD and THC.
It's not a lot of senior one and w yeah,
it's one to one.
Perfect.
It's amazing.
You know,
the,
they work with each other and they help the teach see helps deliver the CBD and
vice versa.
You feel great.
You feel balanced.
You feel like energized.
Clay,
clear.
I don't know about you.
I feel clear.
No,
no problem.
In terms of like feeling foggy or fatigued,
it's just the right amount.
But I fucked up and took one an hour before I went to bed last night.
I went to bed at a sensible time.
I knew I was going to do a podcast with Jessie.
I'm like,
I want to be awake and fresh.
And then I got you based so that's fine.
But I,
I went to bed and uh,
I had taken one,
like an hour or so before I was in bed.
I woke up two o'clock in the morning,
Bang,
freight train,
fill of ideas.
Blam I wrote,
did you write some stuff down the road?
That's cool.
I have,
I keep my laptop right now by the bed.
I started doing it,
the bill,
I just near it near in the bathroom next to the bed.
Literally if a,
usually everyone's else asleep.
I grab the laptop and I just go into the other room and I just start writing.
But I keep it in the bag.
I put it right by my bed.
So if I have an idea in my head twice,
I've written bits that came out to be like real legitimate bits because an idea
came to me while I was lying there and I said I got to just try this and I just
run in the other room and I start writing and then boom it becomes a bit,
not Hawaii twice over the last year,
like legitimate bits have come out of just a random thought that it was popping
through my mind while I was laying in bed.
Now were you,
uh,
were you on the marijuana's both times?
I mean there's something to it definitely when you,
when you have a moment to escape because their brains like an onion dated with
information all the time.
Just daydreaming,
being bored.
That's where the creativity for me is the most active.
Like getting a good napper even just in a dream you think of something like in
the shower or driving.
Those are my ideas.
I've had this similar situation where I'm like,
oh this might be a good joke.
Cause that's my argument for ignoring phones to the,
the allow yourself to get bored.
And when you allow yourself to get bored,
then that's when these creative ideas will come.
Look if you're in your car,
like they'll see the thing about that little car that I was telling you about.
It doesn't have a radio.
Oh that's great.
I know radio.
So you have to daydream you.
You're not just Dave,
you're,
it's like you're tuned into the thing as you're doing a blind man and you think
about stuff like,
I used to come up with some of my best bits when I first started doing comedy,
when I was delivering newspapers,
I would deliver newspapers in the morning and out of my car,
chuck them out the window.
How old were you?
21.
Wow.
And um,
when I was doing that,
I would come up with some of my best bits.
When I wasn't listening to the radio,
I was just driving around.
And then I'd have an idea of what,
why is it that we,
what the fuck is this about?
Just be thinking to myself almost like those hours became productive.
They are
daydreaming has probably one of the most important things you can do for your
brain,
especially for creative people and people in general.
You know,
I think when you're doing something that requires you to do something
mechanically,
like driving,
even just washing your body paper route,
anything that you sort of have to do this like regular machine thing,
your brain sort of just can roam in the woods and just pick off little ideas off
the trees and you know,
you're able to sort of give your brain a break.
Yeah.
Your brain doesn't always need to be stimulated externally.
Fuck No.
That's though,
that's probably one of the causes of mental illness that probably it is
attributed to a lot of neurological issues down the road.
Your brain needs a break,
you know,
those synapses can be firing all the fucking time.
They got shit to do.
I guess you'll give him a nap.
I'm exhausted.
You know,
the brain needs a break.
But yeah,
I definitely,
I think of random things sometimes in the shower.
Yeah,
you can.
You can do that while you're driving.
You can do that while you're in the shower.
What?
Running like I like to run and listen to books on tape,
but sometimes it just like to run and just listen to my voice.
Just the breathing.
And then you get into this meditative state.
Yeah.
That's a deep,
deep bro.
And I'm not,
no,
it's a,
it's already noon.
It is dude.
Fuck yeah.
Oh,
oh five,
three hours of hanging out with you.
I'm still,
it's not enough.
Started a little late because we had some tribe crash caster and we also started
late cause you had me on these mission,
these Moses,
same machines.
Oh that's a sponsor.
The so,
right.
These,
these are amazing.
I have like chronic stiffness in my neck from traveling and sitting awkward and
Jamie was nice enough to give me one of these.
Yeah,
they're awesome.
They're great for look releasing this weird hard to get muscles in your back.
You lie on that thing.
Yeah.
Digs in and it's like real light too.
You can carry it and take it with you.
It's some,
who was the first one?
Was it?
I'm Michael Chandler told us about it.
Yeah,
he,
he was the first guy that it's for the so asked muscle to target it yet.
But where the veet where girls who like that v formation,
that muscle down there,
the dudes who have the Wii.
You probably don't get it cause you're wise.
Yeah.
Jamie was talking about,
I think I that's not as much.
Just go with,
that's what I thought you were assigning.
She'll studying.
I haven't been upgraded.
A fucking podcast is this.
I am a God damn doctor.
Jesse May tell everybody how they can find you on the Internet.
You can find me.
My website's Jessie mae.com I'm at Queef.
He may on Twitter quickie may on Twitter making fun of me because of that.
Uh,
Instagram is Jessie Mae Peluso and you can check out my sharp tongue podcast and
she's touring all over the country.
Hilarious.
Standup comedian,
my friend.
I love you so much and one of my favorites for me on this was such an honor that
we find did it?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Bye fuckers.
I'm a scientist.
Okay.